The joe rogan experience.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I missed the girl,
the girl Joe Rogan experience one.
I miss her.
I'll switch it up next to the next time.
Yeah.
Third girl.
I miss her.
Maybe we'll even throw in
a robot woman or something.
That's good.
Crazy.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome.
Excuse me.
I just got back from Australia.
My Body's very taxed.
I don't even know who I am right now.
I'm in a fucking fog.
I was on the other side of
the planet just hours ago.
I'm here with Duncan Trussell.
These gentlemen,
Duncan Trussell has joined the podcast.
That's T.
U.
R.
Yeah.
Double last devil out.
There you go.
No,
there's an e in there too.
Oh yeah.
Don't say double Estelle alone.
Trussell Dunkin.
That's what it is.
Um,
uh,
he's joined us because he's the fucking
greatest podcast gas in the history of
the unit.
Ah,
come on.
And we've even tone the lights
down because Dunkin's here,
because I took a nap.
I slept an hour on the plane,
flew all the way from Australia.
It's 12 and a half hours,
slept an hour and the plane took
a nap for an hour and then boom.
So I'm on momentum right now,
right?
What's that noise?
I'm trying to figure that out.
That's weird.
Why is it,
I dunno.
It's all the STDs.
Brian picked up this weekend,
June the into the Wifi signal by the way.
Fleshlight rolled up real quick.
If you go to Joe Rogan's website,
I,
you can click on the banner and it'll
take you right to the flashlight website.
And if you put in the coupon
code rogue and you'll save,
what is it?
15% of 15% off discount
masturbation session.
Duncan Trussell and I successfully got
roadie and Danielle Stewart to put their
fingers in my really used flashlight
on the drunk cash and smell it.
Daniel Stewart being
Jason teams girlfriend.
You fuck yeah,
you're right.
You're a problem.
He's possessed by his aides
and it's controlling him.
Is that what right around,
it's like some sort of a parasite,
right?
Like that aquatic worm?
No.
Or that mushroom that like falls on the
ants and the ants going wander into the
pool and drowned themselves.
Or,
I don't know about this one.
You haven't seen that
are acidic fun fungus.
Maybe we're talking about the same thing
I was talking about an aquatic worm
that grows into caterpillars bought or
grasshoppers body gets to a certain size
and then convinces the
grasshopper to go sweat grass.
Arbors kids.
Right.
This is a,
what is this?
Fungus is different,
but I love like what
does that grass hopper.
Thank you.
I'm just not thinking anymore.
What happens is the,
the aquatic rewires his
brain somehow or another,
you know,
it's the weirdest,
like how did that work with evolution?
Like has a bunch of
other ones out there too.
I know there's one that makes some,
some bugs head glow.
I forget what the bug it is,
but it completely zombifies
the bug takes over.
Just lift your leg up so that
way the light's not facing.
Yeah.
I think that might be what that
sound kind of distortion is.
Really.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean like does that sound better?
People at home say yes.
People at home on the treadmill.
Yes.
Talked to a lot of fucking people in
Australia that listened to the podcast.
It was kind of a trip,
you know,
because uh,
last year when I was there,
I didn't have the podcast.
I didn't do it.
Or if I did do it,
it was only like we'd done like a
couple of them and nobody knew about it.
But now,
you know,
uh,
when,
when we were in Rudy Hill,
I mentioned the podcast and
all these people cheered.
I was like,
wow,
like how many of you fucking Pete?
And then I thought to start
thinking about it like,
has there ever been a medium like that
where you can just put something online
and someone on the other side of the
continent can be a weekly listener of this
thing?
That's fucking crazy.
No,
I don't mean amazing cause
there a lot of people.
Yeah,
it's packed.
And then we did another show on Sunday
night after the UFC Sunday night.
The UFC was over at five because
the way the weather it was set up,
it was so it could be live on paper
view in America on Saturday night,
which is Sunday,
early afternoon in Australia.
So 7:00 PM here is a,
you know,
like th two,
two there,
2:00 PM there.
Oh,
so it was live,
it wasn't recorded.
It was live,
but it was,
we shot it on Sunday.
So then we were there Sunday
night and we were like,
well,
hey,
we're going to be out
of here at five o'clock.
So,
uh,
the,
a woman who runs a local club,
her name is Jules,
it's called the laugh garage.
Uh,
we,
we said,
hey,
well let's,
uh,
let's fucking,
let's go do a set there.
So we hooked it up and uh,
just on Twitter pack the place.
Yeah.
Just throughout some
Twitter messages said,
hey,
crazy doing an impromptu Ninja show.
And then we went down there.
It's all these cool
motherfuckers came out.
It was a really fun show.
It's really fun.
It's a small place.
It only seats like 150 people
and it's real tight and intimate.
And just the perfect size comedy club.
You know what I mean?
He's got the perfect vibes,
got all the Shitty head shots on the wall,
all the exact things that
you want from a great club,
good bar,
great owners,
people that love the nominee.
So we did that on Sunday night.
We had a a show there
was fucking fun as hell.
Awesome.
And that isn't that amazing that you could
do that now you don't have to fucking
go on radio stations,
put out advertisements in newspapers.
You just fucking put
it on your cell phone.
Hey,
I'm going to be here at this time.
Go here.
This is the first time I really did
it like that where I did a show from,
you know,
from a few hours to let's do a
show in a few hours ready go.
And it all did it wireless thrilly
wireless leads from cell phones.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
It's the connection that you have with
people now is just off the charts,
you know,
causing some insane shit to
happen in the world right now.
Yeah.
The staff in Libya and the
Middle East and Charlie Sheen,
it's,
I blame it,
Charlie Sheen.
I rarely misses Rogan was ecstatic
about the newest Charlie Sheen interview
cause apparently he kept,
comes off crazy on a fucking loon.
I haven't heard any of it.
He did a new one and he goes up,
the only drug I'm on,
it's charming.
I need to hear that.
We'll need to those actual words.
Cause on the way over to the airport,
me and Ari were listening to,
um,
the,
uh,
the one who when it was
on the Alex Jones show,
which by the way,
it got him kicked off that show.
They canceled production of a show for
the rest of the season because that one
interview I heard,
I just recently,
he said he's,
he's not quitting or he's back on it or
something like that because I knew that
there was a while they were going to
have Emilia Esta Vez feel fill in.
But then I thought,
I just sit on that,
that heard on or read on
TMZ that and now he's like,
no,
I'm not leaving the shower.
Quitting wasn't his choice.
It was them.
Uh,
I dunno what you're,
where you're getting this from.
They fired it.
Why don't you,
why don't you look that up?
Because what they were saying was that
they were canceling production of the
show for the season because of his
erratic behavior and that he needs to seek
help.
He goes,
I'm just tired of pretending that I'm
not freaking winning at every corner at
every turn,
just delivering the freaking
goods over and over again.
And they asked him about
piss tests and he goes,
yeah,
I'll pass the first one.
Second one is in your mouth.
Okay.
It's called winning.
I'm tired of pretending I'm here,
I'm here with the goddesses.
I'm trying to pretend that I'm not living
the perfect fricken life and I'm out
there delivering the goods at every turn.
He's another.
I love him.
I love him too man.
And I love him cause you
got some coconut water.
You got two archetypes going on,
Charlie sheet.
One of them is he just doing what
really powerful guys had been doing for
thousands of years.
When they have a lot of money,
they try to establish a Harem.
That's like a,
that's like a basic thing that's
been in society for a very long time.
That's all he's doing.
He just living like the Western
version of some Roman emperor I miss.
Right.
He was saying that he was like
going to sue and stuff like that.
Meaning I keep,
no,
he's not quitting.
You know?
This is not really,
that's not misread or read it at all,
but that's what he was
saying that that's what,
that's what he said.
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't back down that easy.
This is a gunfight right now between
him and the executive producer.
I know how this work.
Did you hear him?
The shit he talked about on the executive
producer that talks a lot of shit and
he was upset that the guy said something
at the one of the closings of the show.
He said,
you know that I,
I eat right.
I do.
You know I exercise.
I get my colon checked twice a
year of Charlie Sheen outlives me,
I'm going to be really pissed.
I would think that's funny.
I would take that as a joke.
It was Charlie.
I would be like,
you know,
I mean he's going out hunter s Thompson
style man in front of the whole world to
see.
Yep.
I'm delivering the fricking
goods at every turn.
Okay.
It's called winning.
He's got that long
breath that he does with,
it's called winning.
Yeah.
He's delivering the freaking goods.
Then here on papers a lot better
than when you hear it live.
Find a,
the,
the interview,
find them the most recent one because
apparently it's just fucking gold and he
looks crazy as shit and his eyeballs
are bugging out while he's talking.
He,
yeah,
it only drug on Charlie.
She just did a piss test for radar online
and it came up negative like he dealt
with from The Bahamas and pissed
in a cup in front of them.
It's supposedly,
I don't think cocaine stays
in your system that long.
That's not that impressive.
They said that it would have,
well,
I mean,
I'm sure he's gotten it.
There's a trick or something I'm sure
so that it doesn't show well maybe he's
not.
Maybe he's just crazy
and you want to hear,
even hunt doing to hear audio from
this morning is was on the today show.
Yes.
Delivering the freaking goods.
I'm going to get out of Charlie
Sheen impressions I'm working on.
It sounds decent,
right?
No,
that's really good.
It's on its way.
I'm tired of pretending that I'm not
living the perfect freaking life.
The video,
it's called winning.
The only drug I'm on is Charlie Sheen.
You guys get out later sniffle
after I'm here with the goddesses.
That one was good.
That was not good.
I need to hear them and then I'll do it.
I,
it's like,
I need to hear people.
There's only a few.
I'm not a good impressionist.
I'm only good for like Joey Diaz.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So a few people got
sucker that I got nailed.
I know what a goal.
I know what to fucking talk like him.
Like Alex Jones.
I can do Alex Jones.
Charlie.
Okay,
Basically,
you're clean and you've been
clean now for two years.
Check.
Tired of pretending I'm not
delivering their freaking goods.
Fucking hilarious.
Dude,
I need to put it all
together with some material.
Ai Nine one one yes.
Oh yeah,
a truther.
He's gone as far as,
hold on one second.
There were a real quick while we get
over this because this is interesting.
He's gone.
It's interesting.
He's gone as far as to write a fake
question and answer with Obama where he,
it looked like an interview
with Obama when I first read it.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on here?
And then it gets to the end and then he
tells you that it's fiction and wouldn't
it be amazing if he actually had the
opportunity to sit down with President
Obama had talked to them about this.
I'm thinking Charlie Sheen
might be a government agent.
This whole thing might just be his
way of being a patriot and really
discrediting the nine one.
One truth or movement of what he's doing
is he's just banging all these whores
for America.
That's what I'm thinking.
And all the coke and all the horrors and
all the erratic behavior is really just
to make the nine one one truther
movement look ridiculous.
This is what I think,
man.
I think that's high,
like 99% problem.
Mostly likely.
Yeah,
totally.
I'm just trying to pretend that I'm not
leaving the perfect fricken life just
with that,
delivering the goods at every turn.
He's trim drunk,
he's faking the whole thing.
Man.
He's an agent.
He's working for America.
Well,
this nine 11 truther movement can really
fuck up the foundation of this country.
Erode confidence in the base.
And so when Charlie Sheen goes out
there on a deep end in Bahamas with a
suitcase
full of heroin with
different color socks on,
you know,
I mean Charlie Sheen
is out there doing it.
30 years ago,
the CIA was like,
get me a baby.
As developers,
we're going to just your rain.
Hey,
we're going to get them huge.
Just we're going to do it with,
to start him off.
Super legit.
Yeah.
Oliver Stone Movies platoon.
Wall Street.
He's going to be a
fucking huge successful,
mainstream,
active.
Then massive.
Just whores and drugs and,
and then a rebirth on television.
And once we get them on television,
then we've hit the final phase.
Okay.
Because when he's on television,
then he's in the people's homes and he's
little bit humbled because he's not a
movie star anymore.
Right.
I mean,
now he's a television star.
It's not quite the same.
So he's not as,
he's not,
you know,
he's already lost a
little bit of credibility.
Maybe he's already sliding,
you know,
but then you hear he's making millions
of dollars a week and he's about blowing
and doing crazy things while well now
can Charlie Sheen's out of control?
So then you've got to say,
well,
okay,
why is Charlie Sheen into
the nine 11 truth movement?
Why is he doing that?
Because Charlie Sheen
works for the government.
It's a perfect plot.
You really think they would pay him $2
million a week for that Shitbag fucking
show that chose God drunk.
Terrible at show is a goddamn atrocity.
Of course they don't pay
him $2 million a week.
This is just the mainstream news reports
with the CIA tells him to report.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm in there working for
America at every fricking turn.
I got to tell you,
man,
if you watch that show,
I can believe it cause that has to be one
of the most miserable shows that there
is again about working at it.
Like I said this about grace under fire.
When remember when Brett Butler
had that TV show grace under fire.
Brian,
who the fuck are you doing?
Hey,
you got your whole shit on auto play.
Anyway,
when Brett Butler was on that,
um,
show grace under fire and
she started going nutty,
like we're throwing fucking glasses of
water and people's faces right screen.
I heard a lot of shit like that
was when I was on hardball,
the first sip Tom.
Then I was on,
it was like even before news
radio when she was going Nutty,
just like screaming at people like she,
she,
it was infamous.
There's one thing where they,
I believe they cancel the show.
This was the infamous statement that
she said in front of like a table read.
If you fuck your wife,
the way you write comedy,
no wonder why you're divorced.
She apparently said that like at a table
read in front of network executives and
all these people and
threw something at him.
That's one of the great,
the Great Ah,
getting shows canceled.
Screaming a romance.
I've heard two good ones.
Chris Titus is a good one.
And then this one.
But Chris Titus is a nice guy,
so I won't say his over there.
You've got to have to ask him about that
man.
You got to look at like,
I think the,
if you look at how being an
American celebrity carries with it,
this bizarre psychological danger,
because a pretty large percentage of
our celebrities go fucking insane.
Well,
when you Morgan on something bad,
you're f you're miserable.
You know,
and when you're a good comic,
like Brett Butler is
crazy is that bitch was,
it was a good comic.
She was a real stand up comic.
And if you're doing some show that,
you know,
just not good,
like she was a bill Hicks.
Right.
You know,
she was in the bill Hicks documentary
about him talking about how great he was.
You know,
it's like she,
she's,
you know,
she was stuck.
She was stuck making a fuck load of
money on something that's absolutely
terrible and that's
some soul stealing shit.
Right?
Like Tim Allen,
Tim Allen.
Okay.
Was a legit standup comic at one point
in time and literally quit at all for
that show.
Did his show,
did his tool time show right?
Whatever the fuck it was called.
Brian,
we got you one right here.
No,
I was going to turn this off.
Why are you gonna do that?
You get here.
Who gives a shit?
It folks,
you hear that thing?
It's called refrigerator.
Don't go crazy.
Okay.
Problem is we did that before and
then we never plug it back in.
Then it all my food goes bad
and my pot soda gets warm.
That's what I put in front of the sun.
If you're feeling really fucking
frisky where I didn't know that.
I thought this was ginger grass.
I was ignoring that.
Let's go deep juice.
Well,
you hear the interview?
Yes.
What's,
here's some Charlie's Shane.
I don't blame Charlie Sheen.
The show he's on sucks.
There's a reason why he's doing drugs.
Okay.
That's what I have to say.
And I said this about Brett
Butler back in [inaudible] 94
call him passionate eight men start
to get the gas to pull any punches.
Here we go to pretend pretending
like a month special tire,
pretending like I'm not pitching a total
freaking rock star from Mars and people
can't figure me out.
They can't process it.
I don't expect them to,
you can't process me with a normal brain.
The troubled actor.
Also from 2 million to 3 million
an episode if you want to.
You want to race.
Well,
yeah.
Look where they put me through when
it comes to any apologies from she'd,
he says,
CVS execs shouldn't hold their breath.
Do you owe CBS and apology?
No,
they owe me a big one publicly
while looking at my feet.
But it,
his interview with Good Morning America.
Charlie said he's clean,
sort of.
Yeah,
I am on a drug.
It's called Charlie Sheen.
Um,
and uh,
it's not available because
if you try it once,
you will die,
your face will melt off.
And you told him a wee boom,
you're exploded body,
not so sure that's working for you,
Charlie.
He's amazing.
The most amazing guy ever.
Wait a minute.
Pause back that up to the beginning of
the interview and let's go over this
again,
shall we?
Yeah.
As Duncan trussell's professional
stand up comedian and I break down the
brilliant stat is the man Charlie Sheen.
Tired of pretending that I'm not special.
Let's hear that again.
Yes to morning TV.
Oh,
starting with the today show
and he didn't pull any punches.
Tara pretending like I'm not special.
Tired of pretending like I'm not pitching
a total freaking rock star from Mars
cards.
Please pause.
Turn pretending I'm not special.
Did he say Bichon?
Bichon a total rock star from Mars.
I need to listen to that a
bunch of times and get it.
Get it down.
Try to pretend it.
Not much special.
Okay.
Let's for a second though.
And,
and by the way,
I,
I kind of feel vial about getting there.
The way everyone gets sick.
Did this shit cause like it's just
gross when the locusts shut the fuck up.
Listen,
this is awesome.
This
a hundred percent pure,
unadulterated.
There's no need to make excuses.
This is one of the greatest
occurrences in modern pop culture.
You got to fucking guy who makes
$2 million a year or a week rather,
and he's imploding in front of everybody
with coke and whores and braggadocious.
Okay,
so what,
let's just say,
even though he seems to
think he's not on any drugs,
what drug is,
is that cocaine stuff like cocaine.
Fuck,
whatever's look at his
face and seize on cocaine.
Man.
He loves starting to look like a skeleton.
He looks completely wired.
Give that.
He looks like no hands wired.
He loves math or something.
Or it could be math.
I think that's just what I think meth.
Meth.
Like how's a coke?
Yeah.
Well,
if they,
if he,
if he paused,
if he tested negative for radar online,
I don't think you need
more than three days clean,
I think three days,
and you,
you'll test negative.
Especially if you'd take
cleansers and drink water.
So that doesn't mean shit.
You know what?
When did he test Monday?
Especially when you're Charlie Sheen,
you just go,
Hey,
I'm gonna give you $4 million,
make this test right.
And I'm like,
okay,
no,
that's dumb.
He could be manic depressive,
like he can be mad like that.
That sounds like someone and having
someone having either a drug induced manic
episode or just a manic episode because
their brain's fucked up from all the
blow.
And it starts there starting a middle of,
what's amazing about it
is there's two things.
One,
I wish he was a guy who was doing
this that wasn't obviously insane.
You know,
it would be so cool if he
was just really having fun,
you know?
And,
but it's the way he's doing it that he
doesn't realize how that's going to come
off.
It was like,
I'm trying to pretend
that I'm not special.
I'm got to pretend and I'm not delivering
the fricking goods or rock star from
Mars,
you know,
like Whoa,
what are you talking about?
Cause you're a,
because you're good at pretending like,
what the fuck are you saying?
Like you should be weirded out by
the fact that you have any success.
Anybody that's a performer that's not
weirded out by the fact that how the fuck
did I get to do this for a living?
You know,
you think you're special,
that no one who does stand up or
acting or music is truly special.
They're just people that may accomplish
special things and the reason why
they're doing it because
they're on a path and they,
they get on it and then they get better
and then they tune into it and they
figured out.
And that might be special,
like achieving that level
of proficiency with,
with music or with comedy or with acting,
with anything that is kind of special,
but the person that's doing it,
it's just because he kept going,
you know,
it's not,
you're not special.
The most talented person ever is not
really a special person that the acts that
they may achieve by whatever,
for whatever reason,
whether it's because they're
missing some sort of a social thing,
you know,
like some people don't get nervous
around other people and they can begin to
open themselves up because of whatever
weirdness that happened to them in their
childhood.
Or some people just have this unbelievably
exorbitant need for attention that
expresses itself in this really
powerful dramatic performance style.
You know that they can just really do
something that really rocks you and moves
you because they need you
to love them that much.
But at the end of the day,
even the most amazing,
whenever it's just a fucking person
and anybody like Charlie didn't really
starts thinking they are special.
I mean,
I don't know how much of
them is just bullshit and,
or how much of it is just him being on
fucking Xanax or whatever the hell he is
on.
But the,
but the,
when when you start thinking
that you actually are special,
do you think he's just
fucking around also?
It could be.
I mean,
I think about it like it
doesn't look like you though.
People don't care about the
fucking media and what the,
the news tab things and he's probably
just sitting in there getting high
laughing about this whole thing.
Probably don't you think?
I don't think he's taking
any of this shit seriously.
I mean the drugs Charlie's scene,
do you really think he's thinking that?
I think he's sick.
You kidding me?
You don't think there's
something wrong with him?
I think he's just using interviews.
Yeah,
no,
it seems a little,
uh,
these interviews are erratic,
bro.
These are,
these are,
these are not interviews by a man who
is calculated and gone out there and
decided,
you know,
I'm going to act like a wound for a goof.
Yeah.
That's not what you got going on here.
Hey Charlie Sheen's
not that good an actor.
Okay.
There's no way this is,
this is,
you got an issue.
Now there's a,
there's an issue with him like back
that up a little bit and let's listen to
that
one more time.
Tighter.
Pretending like I'm not pitching a total
freaking rock star from Mars and people
can't figure me out.
They can't process.
I don't expect them to,
you can't process me with a normal brain.
The trouble back there.
Can we go and he wants a raise from
2 million to 3 million an episode.
You want to do you want to race?
Well,
yeah.
Look what they put me through when
it comes to any apologies from she'd,
he says CBS execs shouldn't
hold their breath.
Do you OCBs and apology?
No,
they owe me a big one publicly
while looking at my feet.
But it is interview with
Good Morning America.
Charlie said he's clean.
Sort of.
Yeah.
I'm,
I,
I am on a drug.
It's called him Charlie Sheen.
Um,
and uh,
it's not available because
if you try it once,
you will die.
Your face will melt off.
And you're told him when we boom,
you're exploded body.
Yeah.
He's not fucking around.
I think he's just having fun.
I am.
I'm sure I've seen,
I like hookers in porn.
I'm just going to make a mockery of
this whole entire fucking bullshit.
Maybe there's a little
bit of that for sure.
But there's also the
words he's saying that's,
those are the words of an insane man.
But somebody needs to animate
a guy smoking some Charlie.
She is body blowing up and it's coming
up in the leaping over the core.
That's hilarious.
We love when someone's off
the deep end like this,
that love it a society.
We love it.
You know him?
Yeah.
No,
this is way better than Lohan.
This is low hand.
If she had a brain and she
could talk Lohan around,
good.
She didn't.
Good effort.
Dude.
This is a thousand times
better as an archetype,
and this archetype shows up in religion.
It shows up in culture.
Not to take it too deep,
but it's the idea of a god coming to
earth and his followers eating him die and
nicest Jesus.
It happens again and again.
This is a reoccurring thing
and that's what we do.
We get people really famous.
We turn into like,
we worship
them,
we call them idols,
and then we fucking kill him.
I got news for him,
Bro.
Nobody worships Charlie Sheen.
Hilaire you know there are a few,
there's a few like no,
you get that fuse.
Two and a half men start
fellow fans out there.
He's flooded every day
with messages from weird,
mediocre people.
Pretend he's not special.
Yeah.
That's where it gets to your rockstar.
Especially when you're generating
that much fucking money.
It's got to get to here.
He probably was sick of that showed
he's sabotaging himself to get off that
fucking show.
I don't know about that dude.
That's what this is going to carry.
This is going to carry
on much more than that.
There's obviously some sort of a,
a bad relationship between him and the
guy who the executive producer of the
show.
But that's normal.
I don't know.
I can't remember it.
That's really normal though.
That shit happens all the time.
I've seen it happen.
There's always a battle of
egos between the talent.
No Way.
Really.
I unplugged that fucking thing.
I swear to God.
I don't answer it.
I have to keep those.
I'm calling you from your house.
Uh,
Joe Pretty much cock blocked us for
the Charlie Sheen interview though.
It's still get him.
So Doug,
it has your podcasts doing,
doing good.
Yeah,
it's doing good.
The lavender hour on iTunes.
It's one of my,
I don't listen to that many podcasts,
but I listen to yours just because I
fucking love anything you do obviously.
Right.
But you and Natasha
works so well together.
And we just had my friend,
uh,
email on this show and he told me one
of the most horrifying stories I've ever
heard in my life.
What he almost got raped
while he was on acid.
He tells this story on the podcast,
but it's just the most,
uh,
and is the lavender hour.
Which episode does it?
This one?
I haven't put it up yet.
I'm going to put it up.
It just happened.
It's just my friend.
It was my friend who,
this musician in a band called ohm,
which is an awesome fucking
man and the holy science,
but basically just tells the story about
getting in the back of his friend's car
while he's on acid.
He kinda knew this guy didn't know
him that well and his friend's car,
the sides of it had been greased like,
oh yeah.
You told him you were
struggling in the bag.
Yeah.
And so he's just starting to trip.
And in his mind he's like,
okay,
I'm probably,
I'm probably being paranoid.
This guy didn't like intentionally
greased this fucking car and the guy pulls
up.
And did this house.
Uh,
and he's like,
I just got to do a quick drug deal and
he goes into the house and email goes
into the house with him.
I guess he didn't want to sit in the car.
He stuck in the car.
He goes in the fucking house.
This guy takes him into a back
room where there's a dude and full,
a full Michael Jackson costume.
And on the wall is a picture of Janet
Jackson naked with candles around it.
Like a shrine was,
yeah,
in Wa and his friend.
Sure.
This wasn't all pat part of the acid trip
and he was really just sitting on the
couch like watching happened,
two and a half men.
This happened and then like one of the
guys started like dancing next to him
like,
but there's no music playing and he's
doing like air dancing and then both the
guys leave for a second and come back
and they're like standing right next to
him air dancing.
And then the guy press play on a CD
player and started playing with loser by
back and looking on the wall.
There's all these fucking posters on
the wall of due to having three ways and
he's like,
oh look.
Threeway threeway threeway
my friends tripping out.
They fucking play loser by back and
start dancing next to them cause they're
just trying to fuck him.
And he said he ran from
the house screaming.
He ran from the house screaming and he
said the guy leaned out the window and
yell to them.
That doesn't tell you was almost raped.
It sounds like it was almost fucked.
Hello?
There's a,
there's a difference there,
right?
Yeah,
that's a good point.
There's a distinction,
but it's,
we got mind raped.
That shit never happens to me anymore.
I'm Ben Guide.
Right.
What is it ever come close?
You mean ever kidding?
Just being that.
Can you imagine just walking into that
room and seeing somebody dressed up as
Michael Jackson?
You gotta be careful when you acid man,
you leave yourself at the mercy
of the universe and if you're a,
you're going to go do acid and climbing
someone's car that you don't know that
good and then go to his house.
Yeah,
Europe or go to the UFC.
Would you or do anything?
Do you do anything where you were going
to be out there and with a bunch of
people?
I want to know what
Charlie's doing right now.
I want to know what you doing.
No,
no,
no.
I wonder who's doing what and drug wise,
you know,
and all these girls are saying cocaine.
I believe it.
I'm sure it's coke.
I'm sure she's 100%
obviously an amphetamine.
It's like maybe Adderall.
Maybe he's taking Adderall on top of it.
Maybe he's just straight arm speed.
A lot of people on Adderall,
but people were on it fits
into design it every day.
Oh,
really?
Takes it every day.
Yeah.
I learned how to Code in
action script on Adderall.
Is that good though?
Actionscript sucks.
No,
Adderall is a great trick.
It's like scientists like studied
cocaine and they were like,
they came up with a
wonderful version of it.
I took half of one recently.
My first time I ever did it,
he took half of one.
It was great.
Took the second half.
I felt like I was like too much cocaine.
Like,
you know,
you're going to start doing the mouth.
You have the drips and stuff.
It felt like all of that.
It was horrible.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a pretty intense drug and
I know people are taking it.
I guess it gets prescribed for
attention deficit disorder.
Yeah.
And it works.
It does.
It focuses you,
what's the name of that
drugs that make you smarter?
What's that called?
No tropics.
Is that what that is?
Nootropics.
Yeah.
I love that man.
I love the idea that they're going to
come out with a pill that you're going to
be able to take and get super
well what they are,
they do have right now they
have supplements that aid
the function of the brain
that help you supposedly help you retain
memories and help blood flow to the
brain.
I don't,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know.
Yeah,
there's,
there's studies have been done on certain
substances that they've showed some sort
of a cognitive cognitive advantage in
using them.
Um,
Chris,
Chris Marcus,
the guy who,
uh,
from the flashlight,
him and I are putting
together like a little pack.
We're going to try it out.
And what we're doing is like putting
together a pack of all the best shit,
all the stuff that's supposed to be like
really good for your brain and put it
in a pack so that you don't have to
go buy 20 fucking bottles of things.
It's sort it all out yourself.
Yeah.
And so for the lazy
want to be smart people,
you can just buy these.
That's awesome.
Now no one wants to buy a
fleshlight cause they're too smart.
Quit the fleshlight.
He quit.
He left.
And this is the sandwich by the way.
Happy Birthday.
Oh yeah.
Monday happy birthday.
Happy Birthday Bitch.
So what?
We're going to come up with some,
so we'll find out.
We're going to try them and
test them out and see what the,
you know,
it's,
it's one of those weird things though.
It's like how do you know?
You know,
like I take vitamins and the only way I
know that vitamins helped me is when I
don't take them.
If I don't take off,
I've done that before.
I get to a couple of weeks off vitamins
and I felt like flat and everything.
I just didn't feel as vibrant.
And then I started taking the vitamins
again and then within a week I was like,
Whoa,
I feel that good again.
Like this has gotta be the vitamins.
It must be.
It makes sense.
I mean,
you're supposed to be eating
vegetables all fucking day.
Yeah.
You know,
you're not supposed to
beat and cheeseburgers and
soda and whatever the fuck
you're eating.
Yeah.
I mean the amount of vitamins that you're
supposed to get as opposed to what you
do get.
And when you do give
yourself what you need,
like man,
it's just everything feels clean.
Like it's working smooth,
sweet.
I don't know.
We're going to try this
out and if it works,
you know,
if it's a,
if it becomes,
uh,
something that's uh,
that's interesting,
we'll start selling it.
Is that something you have to get,
like,
I mean,
does he have to have like a,
some kind of license to do this or is
the question like the supplement thing,
you could pretty much do
whatever you want to do.
Well it's not,
uh,
the,
the thing about it being like a,
you know,
it's not like they're not regulated
like the food and Drug Administration.
It's not FDA regulated.
You know,
it's like that's one of the
problems with supplements.
They can say they do a lot of things,
but they don't really do,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to tell,
you know,
it's hard to tell what the fuck
has rear re weird and yeah.
And then at one point in time they were
going to call them a nutraceuticals and
they were going to have them prescribed,
it was a big push at the
pharmaceutical companies did,
I think it was in the 90s to try to take
over the vitamin business when they saw
that all these people were spending
all this money on homeopathic,
you know,
cures and vitamins and stuff
like that and health things.
They said,
well,
hey,
you know,
we'll just fucking lock that shit down
to like Monsanto was gonna fucking put a
patent on vitamin C and the only way
you get vitamin C is from Monsanto.
You know,
I mean,
that's not outside the
realm of possibility with
corporate America the way what
they've done with food in this country.
For folks that don't know,
you know,
you gotta watch this.
Some of the documentaries that are
available on Monsanto and see what they've
done,
they've basically done is
they've genetically modified
foods so that it doesn't,
it doesn't have the same effect
when you spray pesticides on it,
it doesn't get killed by the same bugs.
They have a bunch of different things
that they've done to various plants,
but once they have this
genetically modified seed,
you owe them money.
Okay,
this is how it works.
You can't just grow plants and then take
the seeds from those plants and grow
new plants.
You're not allowed to do that.
It's illegal.
You have to buy a new set of seeds from
them and you own those seeds just for
that season.
You buy them,
you know,
you buy them to use them.
It's like you lease them and then this
is where you owe the money because their
seeds go in the air,
you know the cross pollination and they
fucking fly off and land in some other
guy's field and he starts growing
Monsanto genetically modified food,
and then they come in and they go,
hey,
you got our fucking corn grown bitch.
You owe us money.
And they just take your money made.
It becomes like a,
a crazy legal battle with
these poor fucking farmers.
Right.
You know,
and with Nikki could say that some
of them might have stole the seeds,
that's possible.
But with a lot of them,
it's been proven that it's
just cross pollination.
And so then it becomes a real trip because
these people might be organic farmers
too.
They don't want this mutant freak fucking
genetically modified food grown on
their soil.
Monsanto is trying to be,
they're trying to not
just do that with food,
but they're trying to do
that with animal food.
Had tried to do that with pigs.
Like they're there,
they're patenting pig parts,
right.
If they're genetically modifying pigs,
then they're going to
patent those pig parts.
But the problem is like,
there's all this debate about them doing
that because they're saying you're,
you're patenting things that have
already existed for like a million years.
Like that's absolutely ridiculous.
You can't do that.
You can't just patent fucking
parts of animals and shit.
Like you're going to make it.
Can you make an animal that you own,
that you own the patent to it.
And then like what if you want to commit
genocide on the animal that you own and
you gotta just do that.
Just shut them all off and you created it.
It's yours.
It's artificial.
So it sounds like the same
company that made robocop
like they're going to unleash
some terrible thing on the world.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird thing,
man.
They filed in invention there.
They're filed a patent
for the new invention.
The pig.
This is an article on Greenpeace.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
So it's very weird,
They called their invention the pig.
No,
it's a joke.
I mean,
that's the joke title of this,
you know?
But they're,
they're patent plans.
They,
uh,
they're out there.
The world's food supply don't pay.
They're out to own the
world's food supply man.
And they can,
they can,
you know,
it's just amazing that it's gotten to
this point where they've let anybody put
any sort of a patent on life.
I understand that once you
start to alter that life,
then it becomes a real question.
Like,
well,
you know,
I mean,
you're,
you're really,
I mean,
in a sense,
you're sort of playing God,
you're,
you're genetically modifying the,
the,
the structure of a plant to your liking,
and then you own a patent
on that piece of life.
I mean,
it's not your path.
We're allowing people to patent life.
And if it sounds ridiculous with a pig,
well guess what?
It's just as ridiculous with
a fucking head of lettuce.
All right?
It's all ridiculous.
But a patent is,
you know,
the thing about it is,
is the most disturbing thing is the
idea of some corporation just for profit
meddling with the DNA
of things that haven't been
metaled with for a very long time.
That's bizarre.
That's much more bizarre than
the patent because the patent,
just an imaginary thing anyway.
Yeah.
Well,
what's,
what's really scary about it is the idea
that they can stop other people from
growing it.
They can stop other people from having it.
I'm,
I'm too nice.
I have,
must be naive right now because I,
this shit going on in Egypt and Libya,
it makes me think that they're,
the corporate bullshit
like that is just such a,
uh,
is a pipe dream.
Did they,
they will invoke things like that and
there'll be a period of time where the
belt gets too tight,
but I just don't think it works.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on in Egypt
and what's going on in Libya and what's
going on in Iran,
but I don't think anything really
happens without the CIA being involved.
Yeah,
that's,
I agree with that.
I don't think these things
just start happening.
I think someone,
some fucking dude who works for America
is over there and he's helping organize
shit and get people not to take anything
away from the heroic effort that these
people have done.
You know,
especially in Egypt and
when Mubarak is gone,
you know,
and in Libya right now they're
getting gunned down the street.
There's videos.
I've seen a bunch of them online
of people getting hit by snipers.
Yeah.
It's fucking dark shit,
man.
They're just blowing dude's heads off.
Yeah.
Middle of the streets.
Not to take anything away from that.
I mean,
these people really are
doing something courageous,
but for sure there's some
influence there for sure.
Our government's involved in everything.
I think our government does not want
what's happening in the Middle East to be
happening.
And really if there are people out there,
if there's some conspiracy,
no,
because you've got fucking,
uh,
right after it.
Uh,
right after everything went down in Egypt,
they were showing pictures of Mubarak on,
on mainstream press as though
you're kind of a good guy.
I mean,
it's so cool to watch mainstream news
because it's like they have to spend a few
days deciding what tone
they're going to take with it.
And when the Egyptian revolution started,
the United States government didn't
come out and do much at all because they
were waiting to see if they would be
able to push them down to hold them down.
You know?
And then they kind of came
out in favor of the people,
but they had to you.
But there's pictures of
Obama meeting with him,
uh,
many presidents meeting with him.
He was,
I think he was already ours.
I don't think we want
it to get rid of him.
I think we liked him
right where he was at.
But you know,
how do you know though?
It's all speculation.
We might might've like run his course
because at one point in time we wanted
Hussein in there.
You know who's saying was our boards?
I'll Rumsfeld shaking his hands.
A famous photo,
you know,
he was our guy over there when
they were at war with Iran.
I mean,
unless,
I mean our guy,
listen to me,
there's no way to like her teeth.
I wouldn't be surprised if,
uh,
this is some,
I mean I'm,
I'm such a fucking new
age hippie sometimes like,
you know,
2012 coming up and the
acceleration of technology,
what I like to think of this as is the
beginning of people having the ability to
organize themselves in a way that's
never been possible in human history.
Mixing in with the ability to get
information that you could never get.
So that motivates people
to revolt against uh,
liars.
And that's what the Internet is doing.
Just showing who the
fucking liars are out there.
Yeah,
I think you're right about that.
I definitely think that as well.
I definitely think that,
you know,
the social media and you know,
using Facebook and Twitter to get messages
out to where we're going to protest
and where are we going to
meet and that they can,
I mean this is one of the first things
they did in Egypt and one of the first
things they did in Libya is cut off their,
their supplier of the Internet.
They cut off their
connection or something.
But you know,
I mean,
how might mean don't think that the
CIA's and fucking super savvy about that
kind of shit too.
You know what I mean?
Because of course they are.
I know.
I'm not saying that it's,
this isn't,
you know,
it's not possible that it's just
a plain old fashioned revolt.
I just think that the United
States is so clever about,
you know,
the foreign policy and how they interfere
with other countries that there,
they don't ever allow
anything to really slip by.
You know,
when this guy got arrested in Pakistan
for shooting down some people who tried
to rob them and then it turned out the
guy was a CIA operative that was embedded
into the system over there.
You know,
when you find out stuff like that,
it's like,
wow,
how many of these guys are there?
You know,
how many,
you know,
I have a buddy and I've
talked about it before.
He doesn't like talking about it,
but his dad was in the CIA.
He didn't find out until he
was fucking 30 years old.
Wow.
He didn't know.
He thought he thought
his dad was a banker.
Oh Wow.
That's cool man.
It's a trip.
You know,
it's interesting.
it's very interesting.
I think what happens is
something like this goes down,
they have like,
they had statistics,
they probably had think tanks where like,
here's a,
there's a possibility that this is
going to happen in the Middle East.
And when it happens,
here's our plan.
We know this guy out there,
this guy out there,
then let's move in to try to,
to,
um,
uh,
make the situation to our advantage.
But I,
I,
I'm,
uh,
I'm skeptical for no reason other than
it just seems like this doesn't work with
my understanding of the
way a empire likes to run.
Uh,
it's my opinion that this is,
that the people doing this more
than it is a CIA instigated thing.
And I think even if it was
a CIA instigated thing,
it might have turned into
something they didn't expect.
Cause really the,
the one thing we don't
want over there is for a,
what's it called?
At Hedge Hedge Hedge Lemoni.
We don't want the fucking uh,
it to become a theocracy.
Right.
You know what I mean?
We don't want that because this is
another thing that was concerned.
I'm sorry,
but this Muslim Brotherhood thing
that we keep hearing about lately,
you know.
Yeah.
Who are they?
What the fuck is this?
Where is it?
How is this Jess coming up?
Cause this is like an
episode of lost where they,
there is the last season and you know,
they have to introduce some new
character and this new magic guide.
That's one of the reasons why I fucking
gave up on lost the last season.
We started bringing people back from the
dead and Jack started walking through
his lines.
Yeah.
That,
fuck,
I'll never watch anything with that guy.
You see the end and figuring
out how it all makes sense.
No it doesn't because I don't,
they don't get me.
You don't get me.
You ruined me Jack.
You'll fuck I'm fucking goofball
walking through all your scenes.
He just was mad that he wasn't
like a cool guy anymore.
Like he wasn't the beginning of the show.
The beginning of the show.
Jack was the bomb diggity he had great
characters and amazing guy who's out
there doing,
he was a fucking hero and it's somewhere
along the line I bet that act or piss
people off by being a content and they
slowly started making him a continent and
is you know,
became a junkie and a failure and a zero
like his character like went into the
shitter hard in a way that you would
never have expected from like the first
season.
Like what the hell did that guy do
behind the scene there with one of the
writers and broke up with her.
I think they just,
they get to know your real personality
after awhile and I just started
incorporating your,
your douche penis into the script,
you know,
cause I know they do that on,
on shows all the time.
They do that on shows all the time and
people can play apparent like that girl,
what's her name?
Catherine Heagle that's in like all those
romantic movies that make you want to
fucking hurl the movie with Josh Duhamel
when they have to have a kid together
and they're not really,
really the real parents
and they fell in love.
Well she was on that show.
'Em The fuck is that stupid show with
the doctor McDreamy whatever the fuck,
what is it?
You're not Grey's anatomy and uh,
apparently they just fucking,
they started giving her like really shitty
parts and not writing or into mosques
because she started getting an attitude.
It did happen.
Happens.
It happens.
This is Charlie Sheen situation,
man.
Look what they've done with him.
They cut off the last four seasons,
the last four episodes of the season,
they stopped filming.
That's going to cost Charlie $8 million
and it's going to cost them a fuck load
of money to,
because they've already sold the
advertising for those to Verde,
like committed to selling them for
syndication as a syndicated show.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a big loss for them.
They're hoping that trolley pulls it
together and then by the time it goes
around next year,
they can add four to next
year and then you know,
and make up for what they owe.
So this is basically like
for the corporations,
this is the same thing.
It's when like a Roman emperor emperor
had a favorite gladiator and the people
loved the gladiator,
but he got a big hat and
started going a little crazy.
That's what they say.
Is there a little puppet?
It's kind of like miss
firing a little bit.
Well,
you can't have a successful show
without someone being a star.
They become a star.
Whether they were a star at
first like Charlie was already,
or whether they become one like Brett
Butler or you know Chris Titus or anybody
else.
When you,
when you get on a show,
that's what happens.
You get a successful show and
all of a sudden this one person,
I mean you really do fucking need that
one person more than everyone else.
I mean it's really that a mind fuck.
That's a mind fuck.
Especially for actors because
for a giant chunk of their life,
not necessarily what Charlie Sheen,
he was pretty much instantly successful.
But for most actors,
it's a long series of failures and
disappointments and rejections.
And then finally you make
it with something and you
have a fucking chip on your
shoulder for all those
people that caused you pain.
I can't tell you how many conversations
I've had famous dudes that we'll talk
about still to this day about horrible
fucking casting sessions that they had
horrible,
you know,
auditions where it went
wrong and you know,
all the scuffling around,
all the humiliating auditions
that they had to go on and on.
It's like fucking,
you know,
people,
they get in there and they,
they,
you know,
they become famous and they just want to
get back at all those people that hurt
them all that time.
Yeah.
It's like they needed all that absorb
exorbitant amount of attention.
They needed to be fucking special.
And everyone was saying,
no,
you're not.
No,
you're normal.
you're not good enough.
No,
fuck.
Yeah.
And then finally become famous.
You know,
judge saw.
Yeah.
It's like this bounce back the other
direction is so enormous because of how
much is pushing,
pushing them down in the beginning.
You know,
how they feel.
Well,
it's,
you know,
man,
when you run into an actor or a
comedian or anybody who seems proud of
themselves,
it's automatically so
disappointing because it's like,
oh,
you think you're right.
The thing that's making this,
you think your,
you really think you are responsible you.
And that's the most,
it's like a radio thinking that
it's awesome for playing a song
or a volcano thinking it's awesome for
the lava that comes spraying out of it.
It's like,
yeah,
you're kind of like,
you're,
you're a conduit.
You're a conduit.
You're not the fucking thing man.
Whenever
that sounds ridiculous to people
that don't create things though.
And we talked to a person
who is not creative.
It doesn't write a lot
or to perform a lot.
They really don't have any
idea what you're talking about.
You know?
And most people out there are not,
you know,
they don't make the living or living,
being creative.
They,
a lot of people never achieve
that zen state where whatever you,
you've gotten good at it.
Whether it's art or music or you know,
the immediate even dance,
they say that.
And in martial arts I say that it's
anything that you get really good at,
you get into this sort of
zone where it's no longer you.
It's like you've practiced it enough
to the point where you can become
subconscious and then once you do it,
it's like you're just tuning in,
you're tuning into whatever the fuck it
is out there that makes things awesome
and people don't understand
that they don't do it.
It sounds like such an ether thorough,
ridiculous notion,
but it's so widely accepted.
You know,
the,
the concept of the Muse,
you know,
it's so widely accepted that you're
getting these ideas from somewhere else.
That's why I mean when you say,
you know,
I'm trying to pretend
that I'm not special,
I'm trying to pretend I'm not
a freaking rock star from Mars.
You know,
when he,
when he hits says shit like that,
like that is the exact opposite
of the true creative mindset.
Like you cannot tune in to the greatness
of the universe if you really believe
that,
unless it's performance art and
then it's fucking brilliant,
right.
If he's really doing it,
his own Coen brothers for sure.
Well,
yeah.
Then yeah,
I always,
I don't know how many times I've watched
an asshole on TV and in the back of my
head thought if this was performance art,
this will be the greatest
artist of all time.
Yeah.
You know,
performance art turns everything into,
yeah,
but don't you guys aren't,
you guys were skeptical when you see
people like Brody Stevens where the normal
personal,
she bro Steven that go up,
that person is just fucking
crazy and angry map.
But then you talked to him
backstage and you're like,
oh,
I get it.
He is being almost like
character of himself
Brody.
So obviously a carrot it dude,
it's so,
most people think most people
that see Brody think that that's,
that's him.
Yeah.
I think there's a big devastating Brody,
Stevens and Charlie Sheen,
the huge difference between
how they're doing it yet.
So I need this Brody's consent.
Tell him jokes,
man.
Yeah.
Brody's going.
I was over there in Iraq.
Okay.
I,
I was there.
I was in Desert Storm.
Yeah,
I was an Iraqi soldier.
But that's neither here or there.
That's really obvious.
He's joking.
It's really what's,
what's his name?
The redneck comic.
That's nice.
You know,
that's the whole character.
But the big guy that's
on that tour with a,
get her done,
get her done guy,
that guy.
He's a complete character.
But even most people
think that's exactly him.
I thought it would,
but that's just a good character.
There's a difference between
that and an angry person.
An angry crazy person.
He's not acting crazy.
He's just being a character.
Yeah.
He's funny,
man.
Brody is like Brody,
someone where if you,
no matter what's happening,
if you're around him,
something funny is happening.
Like he has a constant gravity of absurd,
hilarious things happening.
Either things that he's making
happen or just stuff that happens.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't just think of him as being this,
you know,
like,
it's not like watching an asshole,
you know,
and saying,
is this guy faking it?
It's like,
it's obvious.
He's faking it.
It's fun.
It's fun to watch.
What's,
when you watch something
like real housewives of
Beverly Hills and you see I'm
fucking Kelsey Grammer's ex wife.
Holy Shit.
What a reprehensible human being.
What a lizard person.
What a just a creepy,
terrible nebula.
Nasty little dried up hooker.
Holy Shit.
She scares me like almost like a demon,
like almost like some low level demon,
like,
like in the,
in the upper upper echelons of hell.
Just like some nasty death warm.
And she goes on Howard stern and starts
talking shit about Kelsey Grammar.
You know when meanwhile you were married
to him for how long you have children
with him and your children are going to
hear you talking shit about him that you
do.
You're going to,
you're going to go on the stern show
just so you can get some press for your
fucking shitty Beverly Hills housewife
thing and you're going to sacrifice all
these years of this relationship,
the intimacy that you guys share.
You're just going to blurt that out.
Like you're a piece of shit.
You're not a 20 year old girl that's
making a mistake and you're some 40 year
old hooker that's cashing in or chips,
you know,
and talking about how she wants more,
I want,
I want all his money.
I don't want this.
He left me,
he left me like,
well,
what did they have to deal with while
he was with you at fucking monster?
That's a price you pay,
man.
For all those people.
There was,
um,
I did US magazine,
you know,
I used to do those,
uh,
me and Chris Mcguire,
which is to do these things where
you look at the way people dressed,
any write things about it,
you know,
you're right.
Like little quotes about him,
and I'll never forget this one guy.
It was a Kelsey Grammer standing there
with Camille when she was in her prime.
You know,
it's when she was a playboy playmate.
She was way too hot for him.
And the,
the,
the quote underneath it said,
it's a story as old as time,
that's all the guy said.
Like whoever the writer
was that said that.
And I was like,
Bingo,
you just nailed it.
You don't even,
you don't even have to
pretend here's his ugly,
goofy looking fuck.
You know,
who just happens to be rich and famous
and he's with this vapid Super Hottie,
you know,
Bang.
There it is.
Tada.
And he's so happy with themselves and
he will go and do these interviews and
talk about how much he loves
her and how amazing it was.
And she completes it and then he
leaves her for a flight attendant.
I mean it's fucking great stuff.
If she was doing performance art,
if she was faking it,
you know,
it would be absolutely brilliant.
But she's not,
there's no way she's
that good of an actress.
She would have been fucking Oscar Wilde
by now trying to be some 40 year old
lady,
you know,
with a bunch of 20 year old boyfriends
that she flaunts on the show.
You know,
before she was even divorced on the show.
That's the thing.
I can't believe I'm talking about
the real housewives of Beverly Hills,
but I got sucked in.
But before she was even
divorced with them,
she was hanging out with all these
young guys that were her friends,
you know,
and that drives me fucking bananas.
I have friends that have girlfriends that
have guy friends and they'd go on pal
around with these guy
friends and I'm like,
Yo Dude,
you know you need a fucking
nip this shit right in the bud.
You're girlfriend is hot and she's
hanging around with a bunch of guys that
she's been pals with since she moved
here to Hollywood two years ago.
Whatever she wants to,
they want to fuck her for sure.
You know,
she might want to be their friend.
She might think that there's
somehow or another keep platonic.
But any of those weird,
creepy situations where you've got
a girl with a bunch of guy friends,
they all want to fuck,
Huh?
Yeah.
All of them.
Have you ever had a girl that was hot
that you were friends with or you weren't
somehow or another trying to think,
how am I going to get to fuck her?
How am I going to get to to
move this into us having sex?
My mother,
I never once thought that about her.
Sorry.
Sorry,
Duncan just went straight red banner.
Let's break this up real quick while
we're here because I'm glad you're here
because I wanted to
talk to you about this.
There's a Cornell study that,
uh,
it was just a put online or a lot of
people are a debating what exactly this
means,
but what they're saying is that there's
an error in the orbit of the moon.
There's an eccentricity in the orbit
of the moon that they think will be,
um,
would be,
what are you doing over there,
Phil?
Toothpaste.
Okay.
There's a,
an error error in the orbit of the
moon that they believe is going to,
um,
it's going to be a,
they believe you can listen to be stubborn
fucking shit brain from 12 hours in a
fire plan.
I'm an entire pretending
I'm not delivering the
fricking goods at every turn.
What they're saying is there's something
wrong with the orbit of the moon that
can be attributed to a large,
uh,
extra solar system planet.
Like they're thinking there's
something out there that's much,
much bigger than Jupiter.
About four times the size of Jupiter,
and this is,
this is just one of several things that
I've been following over the last couple
of months where there's,
there's a bunch of different studies that
are talking about this planet x thing,
but apparently it's,
they're really close to saying that
there is something beyond Neptune,
beyond Pluto is not real anymore.
But something out there like way out
there that's four times the size of
Jupiter,
some enormous fucking planet.
I've seen that.
How have we missed it?
I don't know.
It's a big question.
They don't know.
It might be just so fucking far out there.
It might be really cold
so we can't see it.
You know,
they're thinking that this thing is
by calling it inside our solar system.
I think what they're
saying is that it's more,
it's further away from
Pluto than Pluto is from us,
but yet it's still in some sort of an
orbit and it's huge and it's way out
there.
So this is like,
this is the planet acts Nibiru thing.
Everyone talks about the idea that it
smashes into us every certain amount of
time.
Well,
it depends on who you're asking.
I mean,
do you know if you,
if you talk to,
uh,
the people that believe that,
you know,
the earth was created this way and the,
the,
it's actually detailed according to
Zechariah Cichon in the Sumerian text,
what they think is that,
that somehow or another,
this extra solar planet or this planet
is on an elliptical orbit rather.
And,
uh,
it takes 3000,
600 years to come into line with a,
with earth and it comes near
us and fucks everything up.
And then the Annunaki jump off and they,
they lived off their boat
onto our boat and go,
hey,
what's going on over here?
And then they come check us out and
then make us slaves for a little bit,
make us mined for gold and erase our
memories and fly back in the space.
I mean,
I don't know what the
fuck think exactly thing,
but you know,
when you look at,
uh,
you know,
the,
what the,
the really interesting shit about what
they figured out was that they already
knew back then the,
in this,
according to Zacharias itching that
earth had been hit by a large planet and
that's what created the moon.
We didn't know that until
like fairly recently.
That's like one of the
most recent theories.
There's earth one and earth too and earth
one was hit by something like the size
of fucking Mars or some enormous
planet and it created also,
it created the asteroid belt.
That's another theory about that.
You know,
there's a,
there's a giant,
this is another thing I read them.
I need to find out if this is true or not.
But that bodes law is a law that you
look at the gravity of one planet and you
can extrapolate where the
next planet will be based on,
you know,
how dense the planet is and what the
gravity of it is and that what the mass of
it is.
And it works on every planet in our
solar system except for Mars and Jupiter.
And that there's should be
a planet in between there.
And that's where the asteroid belt is.
So the idea is that,
you know,
something was there collided with a
reason why there's not a planet there.
Did they have any?
No.
I mean,
look,
there's a bunch of theories about
why the asteroid belt exists,
you know,
and one of them being that
it's like some of the early,
the,
the fabric of the very solar
system that it's just like,
you know,
from the forming of the solar system,
this is like,
you know,
some just leftover shit that's there.
And then the other one is that it's a
planet and got fucking nailed and just
destroyed and became this
gigantic belt of rocks and shit.
Fucking crazy.
The idea that planets,
we know this for a fact that not
only do planet slam into each other,
but galaxy slam into each other,
right?
They hit each other.
Sure.
Fucking a man.
Could you imagine,
look up in the sky and every day this
like star just keeps getting brighter,
you know,
and you're some asshole caveman,
you have no idea what the fuck is really
going on and this thing is coming down
and it's going to slam it
to the moon and you know,
and kill everybody there.
So there's also,
there's a lot of theories about the solar
system that are really odd and some of
them that some of the planets that
exist now weren't there before.
Like Saturn.
The Saturn is a fairly recent
occurrence in the solar system.
I mean it's,
it sounds like a total horse shit.
Start exposing herself.
Well,
you know the idea on,
on planets that,
you know,
like rogue planets,
yes,
they get sucked in front.
There,
they come from somewhere else and they
get sucked into our solar system and gets
sucked into our gravity or
any other source systems.
Gravity.
And there's a,
an interesting thing about this Pluto,
this planet that's outside of Pluto is
that they're saying the gravity of this
thing.
One of the reasons why they,
they figured out that there's
something huge out there.
The gravity of this thing is
hurling comments in our direction.
Weird
fucking weird man.
You never know.
Like the thing that
freaks me out is that a,
what do they call it?
Pulse ours or they say like a [inaudible]
star close enough can have like a
super pulse that just flashes hyper Nova,
hyper Nova and were just dead instantly.
Like you're just driving home
and suddenly the sky turns,
you drive home and you
get an Smi hits you,
you're just dead,
you know,
same shit.
It's kind of different.
Know you'd booked di both things getting
Super Nova and a semi hit like this and
mine.
A supernova.
Well for you,
Oh,
you're a,
if you're a selfish con
doesn't think about the whole
rest of the world.
Yes.
It's the same thing Brian.
It's just like me taking pills.
The world will die right now.
I want to listen to some fucking music.
Yeah,
you might,
you might not know the
difference or you might,
did you see that new,
a LCD screen that Microsoft announced
the other day or then this is like they
showed what's in their labs right now,
what they're working on with
the future of LCD screens on,
it's called a
steerable auto stereo three d display.
And what's cool is it's like,
it's pretty much like a a surface
and you can see the surface.
So imagine like an iPad on a table
but really big kind of like their,
their Microsoft surface and surface.
Yeah.
So,
but now you can grab things and it
knows how the distance up and down is.
And you could do like three d kind of
like kind of just like the future when you
see in the movies where they're like
pulling up displays and tapping things and
stuff like that.
And they have this really cool video.
The name of the video is
called Applied Sciences Group.
Smart interactive displays.
Microsoft.
So great man.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll tweet it.
And what's so cool about it,
it's just the,
the future of,
you know,
like surfing the Internet and pretty
soon you're just gonna be like this.
Like you're going to pull up,
take your hand,
grab at a browser,
you know,
just sit there and play with like air
and you're going to be able to like just,
you know,
move things around.
It's like,
it's intertwined like connect
or Microsoft surfaces.
Everything's going to become an
interactive surface no matter what it is.
You won't be able to sell shit unless
it's got like some access to the internet,
everything like this table,
everything.
But what's cool is the depth of it.
And they also,
in the same video,
they were showing the future 3d where
like where it's a flashing these lights at
your face so fast that
you can't even tell.
So we will give you
three d images without,
you know,
the glasses of course.
But it shows how they do it and he goes
into it and explains and shows how it
works and stuff.
It's pretty interesting video.
I'll post it right there.
Wow.
It's trippy shit.
He saw this,
um,
this planet thing is really
fucking freaking me out,
mom.
Well,
yeah,
I mean a lot of this stuff like something
that I think about all the time,
it's like how much are we
affected by the solar flares?
And like a sociological way
and it's such a crazy idea,
but
well,
it's not if he considered that the
moon's orbit affects people's behavior,
is that,
I mean there's say there's
no statistics to back up,
you know,
like that there's more
activity during lunar,
uh,
you know,
other events.
Right?
Isn't that true?
There's no,
there's no statistics to back that up.
Isn't that true?
Uh,
I cause cops always swear by it.
Yeah,
no,
I think there are,
I've heard,
I don't know.
I never really investigated and,
but I always thought that was true.
But if they can figure out
that there's a planet deep,
deep,
somewhere in the,
in our galaxy that they don't know about,
just from the effect that it has
on the moon's gravitational field,
then that means it must be
having an effect on us too.
Like if it's literally
like some planet far away,
it's so powerful that it's altering the
moon a little bit and it would be a fact
that same minor pole,
it'd be affecting us too.
Maybe the storms,
you know,
maybe the weather
it does.
I mean,
look at what,
what sun does.
Just lack of vitamin D.
I mean,
we know it actually makes
something in your body.
It actually causes a vitamin
to be produced by your
body that makes you happy.
You know,
the,
the aides and your
happiness and your health.
And when you don't get that all the time,
you know,
for long periods of time,
people get sick and depressed.
Yeah,
they have,
it's called seasonal affective disorder.
Yeah,
I mean that,
that's seasonal.
If you're in a place where,
you know,
that is a seasonal event,
like in Boston and
Boston during the winter,
people do get depressed
and that's why it's,
it's called,
it's vitamin D deficient.
It's a lot of it,
but it's also just,
it's fucking dreary.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Sunlight lamps,
they're supposed to help.
Did you knew it's snowed in?
Burbank.
Did it?
Wait,
I it like huge chunks of
snow fell from that ground.
Uh,
two days ago I went outside hail or snow?
Well it wasn't hail because
hail is usually hard,
but it seemed like really like wet snow.
Wow.
But they covered the whole
roads and stuff like that.
And were you driving?
No,
it was really early in the morning
and then it melted super quick.
But I mean it snowed all day.
It ridiculous.
Wow.
Well this,
this and a couple of websites here I'm
looking at when it comes to the moon and
one of them saying that the claims of
a correlation between lunar phases to
human behavior does not hold
up under scientific scrutiny.
And they're saying so
they're saying that there's,
there's no connection.
But then other people were saying
that there is a connection.
It's interesting.
Other people think that,
um,
you know,
it's just,
it's really difficult to quantify,
you know,
how do you,
how do you know,
like if it really is a psycho,
how do you know?
I mean whether or not
it's actually called,
but yes,
you should be able to see just by like
hospital reports and prison and you know
police records and when
shouldn't you be able to see?
I would imagine so meaning if
it's a little bit of a difference,
like a 1% difference,
maybe it should be able to see,
maybe that's like that it's just small
enough that it's the rate of accuracy.
You know what I mean?
Like this test is only 99% accurate,
so it's kind of like the,
you know the up down ratio.
Yeah.
This is this one side is saying despite
the fact that no evidence of significant
correlation between phases of the moon,
dimensional cycle and fertility exist,
some people not only maintain that there
is but have a scientific explanation
for the non existent correlation.
It could be that just people want to
believe it or could be just like people
would go nutty because back in the day
it was like bright outside at night.
Whereas before you had to watch where
the fuck you walked and it was super dark
out.
You know,
like a couple of times a year or
a couple of times a month rather,
you know,
for a few days you get a giant spotlight
in the sky and so you could walk around
at night.
You know what I mean?
And probably people did nuttier shit.
If the moon affects the tides is
powerful enough to make tides come in and
tagged it can,
I could totally see how it affect
whatever weird oceans in your brain,
whatever quantum motions
floating around up there.
I'm sure it affects that.
Yeah,
there's that question,
right?
It's like how much of you are,
is the chemical reactions it's going in
your body and how much of that can you
manipulate?
How much of that can you manipulate with,
you know,
an exercise to maintain your hormone
levels and for drinking water to maintain
your hydration.
So you're not,
I mean,
how much of you is a bunch
of these chemical reactions?
I mean,
what your personality,
how much of that is dictated by
what you're taking into your body?
It's quiet.
It's got to be a percentage that that's
a much bigger percentage than the
fucking moon.
Well,
one thing's for certain.
If you are in pain,
you're going to probably be an asshole
to the people around you in some way.
If you're fucking hurting.
You know the old classic when you walk
into the dishwasher with your Shin and
somebody nearby and says
anything to you like,
are you okay?
I'm Oh,
good fun.
Cause it hurts so bad.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
so if you're in pain,
if you feel like shit in,
in whatever way,
you feel like shit for whatever reason,
you're probably treating the
people around you like shit.
He know the opposite of it.
Take Ecstasy and sit next to the
stupidest person on the planet.
You feel so good.
You're like,
I love
you.
Really are amazing,
man.
You really are.
Your ideas are,
yeah,
they're good.
You're okay.
But that's not good.
Right?
Well,
is it,
or is it,
I mean,
is it good to be in wonder
of everyone even retards,
you know?
Or is it,
yes.
I think at the,
I think,
I think it's a,
whenever you get around that kind of
energy coming from someone where for
whatever reason,
when you run into someone really smart,
you get the sense that they've managed
to turn the judgment thing off and their
computer and they just like
you just because you're a,
you're having this bizarre experience
on the planet with them and they kind of
get it.
That's one of the most healing things
I used to at one point in my life when
when someone would be judging me and I
would know they would be judging me,
I would feel insecure,
I would get upset.
I would get like,
wow,
you know,
like man,
maybe I'm a loser or maybe you know,
I would,
if I felt like I was being,
you know,
unfairly scrutinized,
I would just think it was,
I'm just,
obviously I'm a loser.
I'm losing it.
This whatever this is
right now and this is,
this person doesn't like me.
Now I have a completely different
effect now when someone,
I feel like someone is judging me or
someone's being hypercritical or Shitty to
me,
I'm like,
why are you being a cunt?
Right?
Because I'm nice.
You know?
I tried to be nice to everybody.
Like there's no reason why this
has to be a douchey conversation.
Yeah.
It's,
if it's Douchey,
you're,
you're the one who
started the Douchey knows.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think for a lot of people,
man,
that's like one of the biggest things
that they worry about in life is getting
judged and criticized and shit.
Yeah.
It's terrible when you're in,
especially if you're a kid and you're
around one of the powerful personalities,
like decided that you're bad,
you're a loser,
you down and draws that out of you.
It's not like we're talking
about the gravity of the planet.
It's like if someone's judging you,
there's a gravity that they're exerting
on you that can lead you into being the
thing that they think you are.
It's like,
what's that bizarre idea where I,
it's the observers effect when you're
looking at an an Adam or an electron or a
photon.
I think it is that weird thing
where at the quantum level,
things seem to go in the direction
of the way you expect them to.
They seem to be where you're looking.
It's affected by you viewing this,
that,
I don't know the name for that
and I probably just butchered it,
but I'm saying is I think that that can
happen when you're around someone who
has a firm belief that you suck,
you can suddenly,
it'll start drawing out of
you the shitty behavior.
Cause it's like you will start blossoming
out of you and it fucking sucks.
In the same way,
if you're around somebody who's,
who really sees you and
sees how cool you are,
then all of a sudden you're funnier.
Yeah.
You're,
you know what I mean?
Because they're drawing the positive out
of you when you first start dating girl
and she really likes you and she's really,
how funny are you?
The funniest?
Funny.
You're hilarious.
Every time you go to the movie,
you have the wideness shit to say,
you go out to dinner,
you have the funniest thing to say.
I mean,
this was so many guys I know,
um,
that,
you know,
started out doing stand up comedy.
The reason why they got funny
was to make girls laugh,
you know?
Or they,
they started out like trying
to be the most and fun
guy in the beginning of the relationship
when you first meet each other.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's,
that's uh,
I think I'm way funnier
when I'm broken now.
Miserable,
you know,
cause I'm just fucking like,
I don't know what I'm happy.
I'm just not,
I'm being nice and funny to that person,
but like when I'm miserable,
I fucking think of evil,
deep,
dark,
crazy shit.
It seems like to me.
But when you're around someone like,
but imagine when you're
around someone who you know,
thinks that you are a fucking asshole.
I could,
you know,
thinks that you're a moron
and you're around them.
I think Brian's just talking
about performing on stage.
You're,
you're,
you're kind of going off
in a different direction.
But I know what you're saying.
What saying you need like,
I mean,
that was kinnisons whole thing.
Kennison became really
funny because of pain.
Right.
You know,
because of,
you know,
I was married for two fucking years,
this second man is happy
because all that shit was his,
his,
you know,
that wasn't him happy.
That wasn't,
you know,
beautiful life.
Well see,
here's the thing man,
this idea of happiness.
We were just talking about it on
my podcast and someone's was like,
why are you obsessed with being happy?
Being happy is not what life's about.
It's not about getting,
it's not about,
you know,
Oh I feel good today.
It said that it was,
um,
they made a really good point because I,
happiness and sadness are two sides of
the same thing that if you pay too much
attention to them,
you'll be,
you'll begin to get caught up
in like chaos and randomness.
It's a okay.
In the,
in the Bhagavad Gita,
there is this great verse that says,
a wise man is not distressed or is not
disturbed by either happiness or sadness.
There's your mind is,
does not shift according
to your mood states.
You're not plugging into the chemical,
uh,
the chemicals that are making you feel
stressed out or making you feel happy.
Um,
you're above it.
You're transcendent,
you've transcended it.
And that's what I think happiness.
It would be a,
as opposed to the other kind of happiness,
which you were saying isn't that bad,
which is the ecstasy happiness or the
kind of like a happiness that comes when
Charlie Sheen does align of blow or the
kind of hat that kind of happiness and
reduces the Moseley.
Allegedly.
I don't think he's really
a on cocaine at all.
I don't think he's on any
drugs except Charlie's shade,
which is apparently the name
of some new kind of mess.
It's really just a new
method they invented.
We'll call this sheen.
But I think that,
so that's my idea of happiness is not
to get caught up in the mood states
whether you're,
cause you're going to feel like,
shit,
I'm on this planet.
You have to feel like
you will feel like shit.
You know why?
Because everyone you know is going to die.
And if they don't,
it's because you died before them.
And when someone dies,
it's sucks and you're right.
But
that's just when someone dies.
You know?
I think a lot of people think that your
everyday life has to be filled with shit
and that you have to,
that's part of being a
human and that happiness is,
you're saying that happiness is somehow
another transcending above emotions?
I don't think it is.
I think my,
my personal happiness has been fun.
It has been.
Laughter,
having a good time,
hanging out with friends,
laughing with friends,
laughing,
doing shows,
laughing on stage.
That's,
that's real happiness.
So is happiness possible?
Yeah.
But you gotta be around a bunch of other
people that also commit to the same
ideas.
You have to be around a
bunch of other really fun,
happy people.
It's very difficult to go it on your own.
The only way you can is if somehow or
another you attract people as you're going
on your own and you committed to a life
of happiness that also like kind of like
catching into your vibe and then pick up
what you're doing and do the same thing
and then you,
you gravitate more people.
But you can do it.
And I don't think it has to be that
you have to be above happiness.
And it's like my,
my concept of guerrilla Buddhism,
I told you this before,
like people always say that,
you know,
uh,
to be truly happy,
you cannot be attached
to objects and you know,
yeah,
you should be.
You should transcend objects
and material possessions.
I say horse shit.
I say material possessions
are fucking awesome.
Some cars are bad ass.
I'm the drive.
TV's are awesome to own
stereos or great to listen to,
you know,
it's cool to eat a good meal.
It's nice to live in a house
that's cool to look at.
You know,
these are all good things.
The problem is for most people,
you become so attached to them because
they're so difficult to attain.
So the true way of enlightenment isn't
to just be without any possessions.
The true way is to get to a point where
you don't worry about the possessions,
but you appreciate them
when they're there.
It's not that you become
completely attached to them,
but the only way to really do that I
think is to make enough money so that it's
not that big a deal.
If someone steals your car,
you can just get enough
correct.
The thing you,
the thing people like about
possessions is not the possession.
The thing people like is the way
the possession makes them feel.
The feeling state that is
induced from the thing,
right?
It's you know,
like so exam for,
so people like feeling in
love and people like um,
people,
people at begin to associate the,
the person in their wife,
the what I,
whoever they're dating or married to or
whatever is the thing that's invoking
that love there attached to the aspect
of the material universe that's creating
the feeling.
And I think that there's a place,
and maybe it's a legendary and I'm,
I shouldn't even believe in it,
but a lot of,
uh,
a lot of the,
um,
saints and a lot of gurus and a lot of
people who seem very advanced seem to
point to a place that is not dependent
on being triggered by things in the
material universe.
In other words,
the feeling that you get from amazing
stuff is a preexisting feeling inside of
you.
You already have that inside of you and
you're letting stuff be the excuse to
feel that way.
Whereas the idea is you can pop into a
state where you're always experiencing
that type of excitement and
pleasure that you've limited to.
If I get a great job,
if I get a nice house,
if I book some other thing again,
or if I get a brand new car,
if I get the new Mac,
I'll feel out.
I'm going to feel great.
That
old Buddha quote enlightenment
as possible in this lifetime.
Yes,
that's exactly right.
Can it be both?
Can't you have a bad ass car
and still try to be enlightened?
Is that possible?
Well,
that's a thing that's either,
I think there's something,
there's something negative about issuing
those things about about a week or two.
I think it's retarded because then you
get fucking people who are lying to
themselves in pretending to be a certain
way because that how many people drive
a Prius just for the social work
and environmental is
sweeter.
I think a lot of people
buy just from the mileage.
I'm down here.
Yeah,
sure.
Yes.
What Brad Pitt doesn't.
Okay.
No people.
Here's the thing.
People,
people,
people want to put off.
Um,
they want to put off meditating or
experimenting with different forms of
spirituality and tell they're good
until they feel like they're perfect.
They want to approach their like,
you know,
I'm going to be happy soon,
but let me get rid of
this other shit first.
I got to take care of this.
That's not it.
The idea is you approach,
uh,
understanding yourself and the universe
and your connection to the universe.
Not from a place where you
think you're going to be,
but from where you are right now.
Right.
Some filthy,
filthy you no matter what.
If you haven't really meditated a lot,
the chances are you're absorbed in some,
if you're on earth,
you're absorbed in some really stupid,
crazy shit.
And if you wait until you're better
balanced to start meditating,
right,
you're never going to meditate.
Right?
You're never going to get into just
from exactly where you're at is,
uh,
as,
a fucking sex crazed beast or an alcoholic
or with seven heroin needles falling
out of your arm.
Approach it from that place.
And that's where you start
getting really core results,
Matt.
And when you,
when you come at it from where
it's like everything else,
you just have to do it.
It's like,
well,
I'm going to start exercising soon.
I'm going to quit smoking soon.
Yeah,
we'll do this.
Just start doing it.
Yeah.
It's the same thing as everything else.
Say you have to somehow or another
trigger that that action and your,
your brain to force your body to move
in the direction of wherever the fuck it
is you need to do.
Right.
You know,
hopefully we can hack
our brains in the future.
Where will we know
exactly what to do or to,
to,
to motivate [inaudible].
I don't want to be the first though
because there's a bunch of dudes are going
to turn gay because they
tried to get smarter
because for sure that's
going to happen man.
They're gonna fucking stab the wrong
part of your cortex and your just a yummy
cock.
Why does cop scene so yummy?
Could you imagine you come to from
your operation and you're like,
ah,
just want to get it.
Oh,
you look at the doctor.
Damn,
he's hot.
I kids stop saying what if like you could
live forever but for whatever reason,
like every couple of minutes
you just start going,
yummy cock,
show me.
You can't even help it.
You on a date,
you know,
having some of the,
well,
you know,
but really I been gone
to a few plays lately.
Yummy cock.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
air,
you're in the interviews.
You know,
one of the great things about being
a mortal is just the Yummy Cox.
He's a mortal,
but it's meant well.
I don't know man.
I think it's easily possible that they
could fuck up the first couple of times.
I try to rewire the brain
and just create psychopaths.
I love the idea of going to the gym and
putting my brain in the same place where
the kids play it while my body goes
and works out to be the fucking best.
Do you think that if there was
a place where you could go,
where you could go and just lie down
in a machine and the body would be like
forced to do all this work without you
ever having to like exert effort mentally
you would,
you'd be down with that?
Yeah,
I do it.
for sure.
You would miss out the whole thing.
The whole thing is developing the,
the the character to push
through the hard workout,
which elevates your human potential or
starcraft while your body is working
at your body.
Did the hard part,
but that's how you
develop character though.
I mean that's a big way.
There's,
there's a,
there's something that's definitely to
be learned from separating your body and
your mind and forcing your
body to work for your mind.
Or your body's struggling.
Your body wants to quit and you go,
shut up,
bitch,
keep going.
And then when it's over,
you're like,
wow,
I did it.
I got through it.
This is a tough struggle because when
you're doing like you ever do body weight
squats,
you know what they are Hindu squats.
Ah Yeah.
I think I tried squats.
Well it's very easy to do one,
you know,
anybody can go down on your,
put to the your ass to the back of your
ankles and then stand back up again.
It's not hard.
Very few people could do 500 and it's
one of those things when you start doing
it,
you,
you get into it,
you'd do like 25 and then you're like,
Holy Shit,
26 27 and the lactic burn,
you know,
the,
the muscle burn your legs
towards getting pretty intense.
But it's not a difficult thing to do.
It's not difficult to just stand up.
So in your mind it's very hard
to accept that you should.
When when she just stopped,
she just stopped.
Now I can't do another one
and you can't stand up.
You really can't stand up one more
time just with your own body weight.
So you have to like figure out how to
order your brain to work for you and push
through it and sometimes for like a couple
of minutes you'll be an agony taking
big deep breaths and then push out another
one and go down and dig deep resume.
When do you want to quit?
What you want to quit it like 25 or
26 when it starts getting a little bit
difficult,
your brain starts going,
all right,
let's stop.
Let's stop,
Your body's going,
I'm sending you these signals.
This shit is not fun.
Let's cut it off.
And then you have to figure out a way
to to manage that and balance that at
once.
You do.
Once you do have the ability to push
yourself through brutal workouts,
push yourself through like Jujitsu class,
kickboxing class and stuff like that.
When it's,
when you,
you've developed like character,
you develop something new,
developed a,
a control over your body.
The average person doesn't have,
yeah.
Like those fucking guys who can do,
uh,
those,
those divers,
a free divers that I respect
the shit out of that.
I think it's a crazy thing,
but some of those guys who can
go into water for like seven.
That's crazy,
man.
That's one of my favorite things to watch.
Yeah.
Like what the fuck?
How do you power over your body using
your mind and your willpower to control
your body?
I mean,
it has to,
it takes a long time for them to,
to get up to that,
that amount of your breath.
But God made it perfect example.
Like every second you want to quit every
God damn second your body's sending
signals.
Okay.
No,
for now,
for now it's a mirror.
When I was in Hawaii stone out of
my mind from drinking pot tincture,
we went snorkeling and there was our
group snorkeling and then I realized there
was a guy with a snorkel who wasn't in
our group and there's no boat anywhere to
be seen.
And like land is far the fuck away.
And this guy swimming around
and like we're all snorkeling,
he goes under and I'm watching him go way,
way,
way down.
And he's staying down there and
he knows we're watching him.
And he stayed down there
for an impossibly long time.
And I'm like,
it went from me being like,
wow,
that guy is great until like my heart
started beating because I was like,
oh fuck,
I think this guy is drowning.
I think this guy's going to die.
He turns over on his back,
right.
And his arms go out loose and limp
and his body starts floating up to the
surface.
And then he just smiles and waves that
if he was faking drowning because he
could just hold his
breath so fucking long.
And I guess like one of the things he
liked to do in Hawaii was the snorkel out
to the groups and make
them maybe in drowned.
Holy Shit.
So he practices his free
diving by freaking heat.
Cause I really thought he was,
he was,
it was,
he was under so impossibly long.
It was crazy.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
man like that.
I would love to be able to do that.
That would be so amazing.
That's pretty awesome man.
You must have the most healthy
lungs to be able to do that.
That guy's probably never
even had secondhand smoke.
I don't know.
No,
I think it's something you build up to.
I think it's something
just like everything else,
you know,
like the only way you can
do 500 bodyweight squats as
he got to start off at 25
and work your way up to 500 I think
they just developed the ability to,
to hold their breath for,
I know Egan Anyway,
who is a,
uh,
an MMA fighter.
Him and his brother Ensign,
they're pretty famous pioneers and uh,
his brother,
Egan is a famous for being a free diver.
I think he won like some sort
of crazy title and I'm like,
I think at one point in time you'd like
held his breath the longest longer than
anybody else.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure like navy seals and shit,
a trainee to do that.
It's part of bootcamp.
Right?
Probably I would imagine.
You know,
dude,
I told you about my friend Eric,
Eric,
Chris,
the guy who went to uh,
he,
he's a,
he's makes pool cues and makes his bad
ass pool cues and the military and he had
tried out for the seals and one
of the things they make you do,
I believe it was the seals.
I might,
what other might have been
one of the special forces.
What are the other other groups like
that they make you drown like you,
you literally go underwater until
bubbles come up and then your,
your team has to rescue you.
So you have to trust in them
to bring you back to life.
Fuck you go unconscious.
You drown.
They pull you out before
your body is totally dead.
They pumped the water out of you,
they give you CPR and then
they bring you back to life.
And that's when he was like,
I tap,
I'm done.
Yes,
I got to stay up for days and
go run it through the woods.
But I'm not gonna let you drown me.
Have you seen that video on the Internet?
There's an video
on the Internet of an artist doing that,
drowning himself in his bathtub.
Have you seen that?
Yeah,
I him and brings him back to way he
puts up a fucking concrete block on his
chest and his bathtub drowns it cause,
cause basically there's it,
when you suck in water,
there's a reaction.
I think your body as we're
automatically knocks you on conscious.
So yeah,
he knew he would go out and his
friend had to resuscitate him.
Oh my God.
Did you find it?
No,
I think look up performance
artists drown self and bathtub.
I guess like I'm telling you how to
Google or both internet junkies go to the
Google website and type prefer bing
me to drown the live performance art
performance stunt talentless
self-indulgence taking the stage.
This is,
yeah,
it piss people off.
A lot of people were upset at them.
Talentless right?
Yeah.
Well maybe,
but no one's saying that
it's a talent thing.
Yeah.
It's a crazy balls.
Really good at drowning myself.
I was born with this bizarre talent
where I can drown myself in anything.
This fucking won't do.
Website doesn't work.
Yeah.
I don't,
it was like on a weird site where I saw,
I can't remember.
I think that was when I
still use the gap junction.
Crazy idiot drowns himself for arc.
That's funny.
That was the first one was like a critique
of it and this one is a crazy idiot.
Only sites are fucking wanky this way.
It work in either cause it was streaming,
uh,
really.
You know,
come on man.
We got cable here.
That's not what this is.
It's not,
the sites are coming up instantly.
It's not what it is.
It's like the Internet
just sucks my websites.
It doesn't matter if
what your download speed,
it's the,
your upload speeds
product bottleneck neck.
That something like,
Brian,
I've got a question for you.
This is a,
I've got an,
I've got a tech technological question.
Why does Korea have
faster Internet than us?
Most countries,
most countries have faster internet
to know why we're just behind,
you know,
we're kicking ass and making freedom bro.
That shit just gets left behind.
Reason why there's cell phones,
you know,
are there video games ever?
Here it is.
Here's homeboy.
If you just look up a
drowning performance art,
go look at it up on Youtube.
I'm going to watch it real
quick and see if it's worth.
How can you not say,
oh,
he talks about it.
Okay,
go.
Go to it Brian,
because this guy is actually going to
explain what the fuck is going to do
before
I want to,
how many views it has on Youtube?
How many,
let's guess I say 35 times.
I want to know what advertisements
come you say I say 35,000 how many?
I got to put that in 100,000 a hundred
thousand let's say 27,000 shit,
really?
You?
You overestimate the Justin
Bieber fans of the world,
but then again,
you know,
look,
Justin Bieber's at least
seeing a fucking song,
bathtub and beaver is the soundtrack to
a guy drowning himself in the bathtub.
It will quadruple the views.
You know,
I don't know what Justin
Bieber sounds like.
I have no idea what a Justin Bieber
signing angel is that in Brian when a
commercial for it?
No one has a commercial.
This one.
What commercial?
What?
What product are they selling
with this guy's drowning video.
Starcraft.
It looks like no,
some kind of a video game.
Yeah.
Weird.
Hey,
Louis starcraft.
I did a,
another podcast on a
plane with Articia fear.
Oh,
how'd it go?
We were blitzkrieg.
We ate an edible before we
got on the plane and we were,
dude,
we were gone like scary.
Gone.
Like I was like,
it was like my whole body was
like tingling with vulnerability,
you know,
you get to that fits that state that
you're still taking care of and a plane.
It's the perfect place to do it.
Like until you freak out and
you can't get off the plane.
Last time he was on a plane and did it,
he almost had to tell the stewardess that,
hey,
I need to get out.
That's a bit of exaggeration
because he was on,
this is the time he was with me.
He,
uh,
he,
he said,
oh mom,
I almost had to get off the plane.
And I was like,
really?
Not really.
It was just a thought in his head,
but he never really actually did it.
Like you press the stewardess button
and ask if they would mind landing the
plane for him.
Landing and Phoenix really quick,
Kinda to run,
run out into the desert and fun of myself
are,
he goes deep
because I'd like to introduce myself
and did she start off and Murphy Look,
performance artist,
I hate them already.
My work is heavily influenced by Chris
Burden's performance art from the 70s.
Uh,
he's the artists most famous for his
piece shoot in which he had his friend
shoot him in the arm
with a 22 caliber rifle.
That was a wonderful people you're
about to see is a piece of mine entitled
drowning.
I feel that this piece requires
a little bit of explanation.
Hmm.
When water enters the airway,
the vocal cords constrict
and seal off the air tube,
thus preventing any water
from entering the lungs.
This is called a leg,
no spasm.
During this initial phase of drowning,
very little water,
if any actually enters the lungs,
it actually fills up the stomach.
MMM.
My hands were bound and a concrete
block was placed on my chest.
Uh,
this was done in order to weigh me down,
but it also would help
force air out of my lungs.
Or once I lost breath,
you'll see that uh,
nose clips were used as
well in our to ensure safety
attracted to your fucking
drowning yourself.
Wait for me to go unconscious and then
immediately pull me out of the water that
in Cox it sounds so.
I think that's pretty much it.
Let's watch
like how,
how many minutes did his friend think
about not picking up that block?
I wonder how long you went under four.
And so this guy's in his
underwear is now of course.
That's a bitch ass move.
If you're going to drown,
you should be balls out.
Fucking let your cock hang outs on.
Get Yourself.
Come on,
man.
You're afraid we're going to see your
penis while you're drowning and now you're
showing us your ass there Sonny boy,
you're dying in a tub and you're
worried about people seeing your penis.
You fucking pussy
fucking fake crazy person was
a cinder block on his chest.
By the way.
That cinder block ain't
stopping me from drowning.
Bitch.
I'll stand right the fuck up.
Is that real dumb?
So he's this guy just going to start
breathing now what happens here?
And he's just laying there with
a cinder block on his chest
that's somehow somewhere around the,
I guess he's going to like take a breath
of water in a half to get here and you
won't be able to get out.
So he's just holding his breath
right now as long as we can.
So what the fuck happened to this
guy while we're going through this?
Because it's probably
going to take a minute.
What the fuck happened in this guy?
That he wants to drown himself in a tunnel
that affected way he talks.
Makes me want to kick him in the balls,
doesn't it?
For the arts.
Joe Work is heavily influenced by
another Douche bag from the 70s he shot
himself in the arm.
It was amazing piece.
His piece called shoot me.
This is combat of is called
the most unoriginal names.
This is called Johnny.
Well,
I mean that's what it is.
Why call it anything else?
Right.
Fucking put some icing on it
and come up with something.
I don't know man.
He stay still.
So while we're pausing folks,
this guy is still just
lying there in the tub,
holding his breath with his eyes open.
Yeah,
he hasn't given up yet and
he's getting ready to give up.
He starting to spouse cause this
is towards the end of the video.
The,
the beautiful thing about youtube is you
could see that little bar at the bottom
there.
He goes,
there he goes,
he's,
he's breathing now.
Oh this is fuck.
Oh my God.
Because they got him on the floor
now and now they're doing CPR.
Okay.
Oh this is so fucked.
The guy's blowing in his mouth
right now and he's still not back.
He's still done.
I guess his guy,
hopefully this guy really
knows how to do CPR.
Right?
Guys,
last couple of years ago,
ever done this to a live body
before you want to show hill.
It spans lifeguard type character.
This is scary shit.
Okay.
He still is counting.
He's looking up and counting
and I'm blowing into this guys.
I don't see a lot of effort on his
party that don't say I'm really fucking
passionate in that area.
This is fuck man,
this guy is still under or dead or drowned
or is it brain cells dying right now?
Isn't,
isn't this,
how many minutes does it have to be?
Because it hasn't been that many
minutes is the guy was under that
it.
Yeah.
What if they did it and they're both
assisted at sound that you heard this,
his friend running back into the room.
Right?
Whoa.
Wow.
And now he's back to life.
Shit.
Holy Shit.
What the fuck man,
that took a long ass time.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
It's pretty fucked up to that is a trip.
Let's see at the end,
Brian and see if he's
got something stupid.
Say I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck I was thinking.
Don't try this at home.
Wow.
We are all fascinated by that transition,
you know,
from here to there.
From present to not,
yeah.
From life to death.
From,
yeah.
From here to gone.
You know,
we're all fascinated by that man.
The death of the body.
How often do you trip about that?
Dying a looker I got for you,
by the way.
Do you keep forgetting?
I got your notebook that you
left here when you lived here.
We're not going to read from that.
He Joe's already read through it.
I heard about the weight.
You have to say about ponies.
Thanks and love this thing.
It's been burning a hole through my check.
You're just lucky that
you didn't become famous.
You lucky he didn't become famous in
the time between a living here and going
out on your own because I would've sold
that fucking thing if you were Charlie
Sheen.
I'd be on the today show right now.
I have the document that is a true
friend to give this embarrassing journal
back.
Well,
this is the journal that Duncan Duncan
got the boot from his missus back in the
day and uh,
live with me for a few months.
Best roommate ever by the way,
the only one that's ever cleaned.
I've got a couple of guys live with me.
No one that ever like actually kept his
room clean as Dunkin Tate live with me
for a few months and was like,
goddamn tornado in there.
I was,
it takes a fucking savage tape.
Might as well.
I just might as well
just cut a hole in the,
in the side of the hill.
And Tate would've lived in there
just to say game Tate's crazy.
But um,
anyway,
Dunkin wrote this,
a journal about his feelings in the
relationship and the reason why I brought
this up,
the reason why my mind even went to it
in the first place is because a lot of
people are scared or the isolation tank
for the same reason they're scared to
death,
right?
Because it almost is like
a personal death of you.
You know,
like a temporary death of
you for a brief moment.
You,
you cease to exist when you go into that,
that tank,
that tank is also
something that helps you.
And this is where the connection
to this journal comes from.
Juan,
you were going through this breakup.
You kind of reassessed your whole life.
It was really interesting to watch.
You know,
you,
you came when you called me up and you
were really bummed out and she kicked you
out and you were in a
hotel room and I'm like,
Hey,
you fucking come live with me.
And then you moved and you were like,
just a little frazzled.
You were like,
yeah,
thanks a lot man.
I really appreciate it.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm living by myself.
This is all good.
You know,
Dunkin's live with me now.
We're going to have some fun.
It's been a pretty dude.
Everything's going to be fine.
But you were clearly like lost,
you know,
you,
you would like gotten,
you know,
when you get dumped man,
it's like just fucking feeling of shit.
I don't have a home anymore.
Yeah.
Like where am I sleeping?
Massive.
Like just towards your
junction change complete.
You've been living this
certain way along enough to,
to get used to it and then all of a
sudden everything absolutely changes.
Like just a huge tour turn that
you probably thought could happen,
but you're,
you know,
trying to imagine that it
wasn't even a possibility.
And it happens.
Well that,
yeah,
that's like,
you go into shock,
you're attached to a certain rhythm,
a certain pattern,
a certain set of surroundings
that massively changes you.
You go into shock and that is the perfect
time to get in a fucking flotation
tank when everything's discombobulated
and floating around inside of you and all
the,
all the,
uh,
weird assemblage of emotions.
And more than anything though,
what's cool about that shit is
you get a real taste of truth.
Like that's what truth is right there.
That's like the experience of truth,
which is change,
which is dramatic,
radical change.
Fucking unavoidable happens all the time.
Did the,
the isolation tank keeps you
from distracting yourself
and makes you think about
your life?
Yeah.
It makes you think about what's going on.
So for me,
it was so fascinating having you here at
a real low point and watching you pull
right out of it right out of it,
like very quickly.
Like you,
when you got into that tank
and within a few weeks,
Matt,
you were laughing about shit
and joking around about it.
Sure.
Yeah.
They always cool.
It was.
Yeah,
it definitely,
definitely helps.
And that's why you're this,
my friends are so important.
Cause like if you don't have friends
and you get into that predicament oh
terrible.
It's the worst feeling
it feel completely alone.
Yeah.
And,
but you know,
even if you don't have friends,
you can still pull yourself out of it,
but you have to I guess really want,
you know,
you,
you have to want to,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
I mean it's,
look,
anyone can can improve their surroundings
so you can improve your situation.
But it was really interesting
for me watching you because
it was such an unusual
opportunity for both of us.
It was an unusual opportunity for me to
watch someone who didn't have a lot of
experience with a tank,
but who was such a curious person and
psychedelically experienced like you and
then have access to this thing on a,
on a daily basis,
you know?
And for me to watch you
go from this really low
point to like,
like really like gaining ground.
Like you came out of it like stronger
fucking cool climbing out of that thing.
In that state of being in the,
in the state of like having had,
because you know,
their second psychedelics
are not limited to drugs.
There,
there's many ways to induce
a psychedelic state of mind.
The tank being one of them.
And um,
another way to induce a psychedelic
state of mind is to have dramatic change
happen in your life that
rips back whatever delusion
you are living by and shows
you
the true universe.
Yeah.
People turn the term psychedelic to a
lot of people means like seeing things
that aren't their hallucinations,
dancing mice,
you know,
Shit like that.
Pink elephants flying in the sky.
That's not a real psychedelic state.
The real psychedelic state is
the dissolution of cultural
conformity and the Ah,
your ideas of the universe,
all your predetermined
patterns of thinking all your,
you're adopted behavior patterns,
all that gets stripped away and you're
left with the core of you and your
decisions and,
and what,
what you can and can't change.
And how you led yourself into a position
where you were so weak in the first
place that you,
you know,
you needed saving from.
Like what?
What were,
why did you have no foundation?
Why did you fall apart?
Like when,
what is it about,
you know,
life and about trying to get by in
this world that leaves us so fucking
vulnerable sometimes and so in need of
other human beings is to stack us up and
to hold us up and watching you
man was really fucking cool.
It was really cool because
you really used it,
man.
You got in there all the time,
you know,
and you were,
you were getting out and
talking about it and it was,
it was a fucking trip,
you know?
I don't know if you wrote it about it
in the thing because I didn't read it.
I,
I've had that thing for years.
That's it.
And even take a look at that.
I dread to him over the phone and
then he made me stop and I said,
all right,
I won't read any more of it.
I was just two years ago I got thing
has been sitting in my fucking,
my office for tariff.
I think it's like 2004
so what year was this?
Wait til I didn't date it.
2004 or 2005 I believe it was.
Yeah.
It's cool though.
I mean you're,
you,
you got a window into a
certain time in your life.
You know where you were.
You were in the shits.
Well,
I'll tell you,
man,
that unfortunately happens.
But you know,
can you say that?
But I don't think it's unfortunate at all.
Oh,
right.
I got you.
If you were stuck with that check now.
No,
Jesus Christ.
Think about that.
Think about your situation now and
thinking about your situation then.
How much happier you are now,
right?
You could have been stuck.
I mean,
if,
you know,
if you talked her in to taking
you back or something gross.
Oh,
with a child or something.
You know what I mean?
It's funny how you,
you,
you're a different human now.
You're so much more confident.
You know?
It's one of the things that I
saw when you went up in Montreal,
right?
Like even your sats now,
you're so much more
confident he'd go up there.
You're so much more.
You,
you know,
you're so much more,
what's the word,
you,
you were resigned to who?
You are not,
not resigned rather,
you're not the right word,
but it's not resigned that that's cause
that sounds like you're giving up.
It's not,
that's not what I mean.
You're,
you are completely aware of who you are.
That's the best way of saying it.
When you're going on stage
now you're going on stage,
not trying to convince them of anything.
You're just,
this is me and this is what I'm
doing is what I have to say.
Whereas before you were like,
Hey,
I hope you like me.
Do you like me?
You don't like me.
Well here I'm gonna say something,
I guess.
I guess that weirded me out.
Okay.
I think the reason the word
resigned popped out of your
mouth first is because I
think there is a certain level of being,
and it sounds like it's
like I'm giving up,
but resigned can also be like a
kind of surrender where you're like,
I'm just no longer going to spend time,
whether on stage or off stage.
I'm not going to spend time anymore.
Trying to convince myself or other
people that I'm some certain way and I'm
going to start trying to approach
people from where I'm at.
Yes.
Which is,
which is not a perfect
place for most people.
Most most of us are,
you know,
have fucked up things that we do.
And why wouldn't you?
I mean,
you're going to look at where you're at.
Like you say,
we're in a fucking ball
flying through fucking space.
How are you supposed to adapt
to this in some brilliant way,
right off the bat,
you know you can,
it's a champ.
You're in this insane dimension where
were getting rocketed through space where
you're gonna die.
You're surrounded by people
who call themselves your
family that you're supposed
to have attachments to.
They're going to die.
You're in a life where you've just
adopted certain modes of being.
I didn't have a baby,
I didn't get married,
but a lot of people do when they weren't
ready and they weren't supposed to and
they get married,
they have a baby and they are
theoretically for this incarnation,
pretty fucking trapped there in
a lot of people are.
A lot of people haven't yet.
They have all kinds of weird
situations where the relationship,
they're stuck somehow or another,
whether it's because of a mortgage or
because of a business that they started
together
me a mental idea of how
things are supposed to deal
with some person or you give
birth to a child that has like a a melted
brain and you've got to take care of
like a little like sick kid for 12 years
or like there's so many different ways
that your particular DNA can get regulated
down into a shitty trap where you're
just like there.
It's like a,
that's why I liked that movie.
You said you didn't want to see it and
I'm sorry if you've seen it in like it,
but what was that hundred and 27 hours?
Did you see that?
No,
I didn't see it because
I knew the story and I,
you know,
I don't want to watch it.
It's a torture movie.
There's no reason to watch it.
Everybody says that it's a torture movie.
Like it was fixated on the Gore or the,
but it wasn't,
it's a fucking metaphor,
which is that,
uh,
some times doing the thing you
love to do whatever it is and,
and that's for a lot of people's
doing the thing you love most,
you can end up getting
your goddamn arm pen.
Yeah.
You're,
you're connecting someone having
a baby to cutting your arm off.
That's funny.
No,
I'm kidding.
I'm not connecting if you have
a baby for the right reason.
No,
I know what you're saying
for the wrong reasons.
I know,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
You were saying what a lot
of single people with no
children say and what you're
saying is,
you know,
we were talking about our friend who
tweeted something about having a child is
like the exact opposite
of winning the lottery.
Yeah.
I used to think the exact
same way until I had children.
But my situation is
very different in that,
first of all,
I'm older,
I've had more experience in life and um,
I'm secure financially and
happy in the relationship.
So it was all good things at a good time.
But when I look back
on past relationships,
some of them,
there was a bunch of
relationships that I've been in,
you know,
like way back in the day when I was
younger and I really didn't know what the
fuck I was doing and I was hanging
around with chicks that I probably really
didn't even like that much,
but I was still having sex with them.
And sometimes you'd have like a
crazy fucking breakup are crazy bad
relationship.
That person could be out there with your
kid and then you have to deal with all
kinds of nonsense that comes with that.
I mean,
we all know somebody that has kids,
you know,
shit situation.
Yeah.
So I,
I hear what you're saying man,
what did but that,
so what,
yeah,
what I'm really saying is like the,
the idea and it goes back to what we're
being comfortable resigned to who you
are.
That's where I didn't like
the way I said resign though.
I didn't mean reside.
I sometimes,
sometimes you have to be resigned,
you know what I mean?
Not all of us are fucking Charlie Sheen,
not all stars from Mars.
Not all of us are a freaking
rock star from Mars.
Yeah.
Some of us are like,
you know,
we all don't to pretend that
I'm not special or fucked
up and a lot of ways man,
and,
and that's,
if you start from,
it's like,
you know,
one thing that I would try to
do when I used to work out,
and it's like when I,
when I,
when I first started working out,
how would try to lift weight that was so
much more heavy than what I should have
been lifting out of this sense of
like I could lift heavy weights.
And so now I'm like trying
to live like way too.
Why am I like,
why should be at the fucking pink weights?
And I'm like trying to do a quick,
you know what I mean?
I'm trying to do like really fucking heavy
weights cause it's like this is how I
see myself down the line after I've
been lifting pink waits for a while.
That's how you get to the heavyweights,
right?
But if you start off right away trying
to pump those fucking heavyweights,
then it's disaster.
You're going to pull your
fucking muscles like people how,
you know,
like due to lifting weights.
One Guy I think came up to me,
he's like looking at me
like what are you doing?
He's like,
that's way too much weight.
And so this is like having a kid when
you're 16 having a kid when you were 16 or
deciding that you're a
famous comedian before you,
are you getting on stage after a couple
of months and getting in your fucking
head that you're like,
you've been doing standup for 15 years
or being a fucking painter when and like
just immediately thinking you're a great
painter because I've had friends who've
into painting,
right?
And they've only painted for a year and
they show me some of their paintings and
the look on their face is like,
I'm supposed to react to it.
Like I'm seeing a Picasso or something.
It's like
I hate almost everyone that shows me
things that I'm supposed to look at that
they did almost every time
someone does that to me and Mike,
are you really going to do this to me?
Mom,
please don't make me
read your fucking script.
Don't ask me to read your script.
You Fuck Hey Daddy,
you read my script row.
It's the worst.
The worst is when it's bad and then
you're obligated to talk to them and go,
all right,
here's the situation.
You know,
you basically did men and black meets
back to the future written by a 12 year
old.
You know,
like it's like
you can't even say that.
You have to go,
wow,
it's pretty good,
man.
It's pretty good.
Well,
now see that's the thing.
That's where you get,
and I think kind of what
we're talking about,
which is like at some point
you have to make a decision.
Am I going to spend the rest
of my life lying to the world?
Am I going to spend the rest of my life
meant trying to manipulate people around
me because I'm too lazy to tell them
the truth or am I just going to start
telling the truth?
Well what if it though,
if it's a friend that's written
something really cool though.
What if someone who's
got a script and I mean,
so that's the problem with
all the shitheads that want
you to read their scripts
and makes you super skeptical for the
occasional rare person and actually write
something good.
Right?
And it's just like,
Hey,
I think this is pretty good.
You want to read it?
And then you're like,
all right,
I'll read it.
You know what I mean?
How many,
how many of those are there?
People I know who are
really good at things,
they don't ask me to look at it.
I ended up looking at it cause I want to,
yeah,
like my friend email,
he just visited like his
music's fucking good.
So like I try to get new cds of his
cause I want to listen to it cause it's
really fucking good.
Yeah.
But sometimes somebody else sends you
something or somebody be in their car if
they're a musician and then
they'll put their shit off.
You have to listen to it
or do that.
That is ever let a musician drive.
I never let them get in your car with
a CD in your hand to your fucking hand
cause you're suddenly,
you're forced suddenly not
just to evaluate how miserable
and artists they are,
how cliche and shitty their music is.
But also you have to re you realize
that the fact that they felt comfortable
playing this for you means
they think it's good.
Yeah.
These are they,
they're so diluted and so fucked up.
They were like,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to I,
they've been waiting all day to
play their music because they
to a script or a piece
of music or a joke or,
I mean how many times have you had a
friend who's just starting out and they
have a bit and you've got,
you want to tell them.
I came in and you need to drop that bit.
That bit.
Yeah.
Good.
I'm like,
no,
no.
It's good.
Just to,
this is a bad crowd tonight.
I'm been doing it.
It's been killing you.
You're fundamentally looking at the
whole premise and what he's saying and
you're like,
this is a shit joke dude.
Terrible.
Yeah.
Someone clunker.
If someone's just been doing,
if someone's been doing
standup for less than a year,
I don't even critique their material
cause I know they're going to grow out of
it and it's going to change
and it's going to get,
it's like,
well there's the first year of stand
up.
You can't do any.
You're lucky if you're,
if you're really,
well isn't that like a any bay,
it's only takes a couple of things to
add to something and that's the whole
point.
It no bit starts off like a grade,
a bit from the beginning.
Usually it's usually you have some kind
of idea and you tried to go through it
and then like add to it
and make it an actual bit.
Right.
So that's what's weird about me.
Cause like I'll go on stage and people
come up to me and go to that bit sucks or
whatever.
But I'm like,
yeah,
but this is like the second
time I've ever said it,
you know?
So you know,
the thing is it's like there's no
fucking rules about about it or anything.
It just takes a long time.
I mean,
and
Vance and someone who's only
been doing comedy for a year,
you know,
you're doing pretty good right now.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you're,
you've also had the opportunity to do,
do stand up,
take off for five years and be around
high level standup comedy on a regular
basis.
You're always at the Improv.
You're always at south.
You go on the road,
you see Joey crush and Ari crushes.
See me do my sets and
saw all these fucking,
this comedy is in your head.
I mean,
you're getting to see like you
get to see bill burr all the time.
Whenever he's in town,
you see Louis C K you've seen the ship,
how you've seen so many fucking comics,
man.
He's like,
your exposure to high level
standup comedy is much,
much more,
uh,
you know,
it's a much deeper than
the average open miker
definitely.
But it doesn't help me write anymore,
you know what I mean?
That's,
that's what I did.
Like yesterday,
yesterday I was like,
all right,
I'm going to do no new.
Like this is all new jokes night,
you know,
yesterday.
Right.
And I was like,
fuck,
I didn't write anything.
So I'm like looking
through my notes going,
okay,
there was an idea.
There's an idea,
there's trying to make bits,
but I didn't write any of this shit out,
so I want to stage,
I pretty much did,
had nothing,
you know,
it's,
it's funny like writing into
me or at least thinking of,
you can go on stage balls out like
that with nothing in your head.
You have to have some materials.
Right.
Well usually I like this kind of,
yeah.
Do
those of your Joey throwing
around doing it a long time?
Like I'll go on stage sometimes and I'll
fuck around and I don't know what I'm
gonna say.
Like I came up with that
bit about the birds.
Again,
there's birds are falling from the sky,
you know,
and everyone's like,
oh,
it's a fucking apocalypse man.
Look,
the burns,
I'm like,
one thing that you don't
consider is that birds are cunts.
Okay?
First of all,
who cares about birds
falling from the fucking sky?
Birds don't give a shit about you.
They're surviving dinosaurs.
And second of all,
why do we think that it's apocalypse?
Maybe at some one badass worm becomes
a sorcerer and just decides to get back
all these conti birds that had been
fucking with his family for generations.
And you know,
he's wearing a wizard's
robe and he's just,
it's called winning,
you know?
So this,
this bid,
I,
it's turned into a bit and
it came out out of nowhere.
Literally.
I had no idea what I was going to say,
but I knew that if I had no nothing there,
I have another bid ready.
That is actually a bit.
All right.
And so because you have like these little,
these little bridges,
you know that,
you know that you have this be,
this bridge is built.
I'm going to go right into fire
at the San Francisco Hotel.
Boom.
It's right there.
It's solid.
And so I know that I can take a chance
like let's just swing off this vine and
hope I can catch that bridge or you know,
or catch up on that.
I didn't know was there.
How cool is it when that start,
when you start killing
and you're improvising and
your end depth bizarre like
wave where suddenly you're
not doing any jokes and then
sometimes I've improvised and done well
and then tried to go back and do it.
Joke.
Yeah.
And it doesn't do as well because they
were so used to that stuff that was
coming in the moment.
Yes.
Like that's a weird thing
man where you can tell too.
They feel it.
They sense it.
He's doing material as well.
And then also they can tell
that you're free ball and two,
I can tell him when Joey Diaz free balls,
like sometimes I'll
run up to him offstage.
I go,
did you plan that one?
And they'll go,
Nah,
I fucking came up with the right there.
Like the,
he did a joke about his dick,
but he was doing his thing about Viagra.
This was the Sunday night
show him [inaudible] he was
doing the thing about you
and you'd have a copter dead Dick.
He never cut the dead Dick.
He goes,
if your Dick's dead,
this is what you do.
You go out of total fucking refrigerator,
you'd get those popsicle sticks
and your rep that Dick Up.
I got fucking wounded
soldier send it back in.
He was talking about putting your ticket,
a splint with popsicle sticks
and the way you saying it,
it was fucking,
it was so it was,
there's a feeling of magic as he was
saying this and he is killing before he
says this.
So he goes into this like
red faced like Joey Diaz,
purple faced,
screaming spits flying out.
You never copped a dead Dick.
You send that thick in
like a wounded soldier.
And me and Ari were fucking crying,
laughing and I couldn't wait to for him
to get off stage so I could ask him.
Was that off the top of your head today?
He said it came out of nowhere.
Just came out of nowhere.
Like all of a sudden it seemed like a
bit like it was all there and it was
because he was willing to swing just
to take this chance and see where,
where it brings you.
You have to be able to do that though
in front of several hundred people is
rare.
Like you,
your stage right now,
you can't quite do that yet.
What your stage right now when you got
to do is you've got to write things down.
Well my at that though with the come on
your face that that was made up onstage.
What Ben?
Is that the pets?
Oh well yeah that was a line you came
up with a line for an already existing
pit?
No,
no,
no.
That whole bit was written onstage.
Really?
Yeah.
And it just came up on one day.
I don't know,
it was the Sunday show.
I mean,
so that's what I been talking about.
I'll do that all the time where I'll
think just like either on stage or walk.
Right when I'm going to,
like the other day I
had this thing where it
talking about that before
you ever did it on stage,
Brian,
you've talked about that a few times.
What before you had been talked
about the ex girlfriends,
how the you,
you have these pets from them and
they all have the same personality.
Yeah,
but I didn't it,
I mean when the first time I went to,
I thought of that bit,
I was sick,
seriously waiting for the [inaudible]
in front of me to get off stage and I'm
just thinking like I got to do something
about my animals cause I flick,
I'm a single mom right now.
And so I went on stage and they've said,
hey,
you know,
I feel like a single mom.
Oh blogging when you talk to me about it,
you'd already done it on stage.
Maybe it's that.
Yeah.
I don't like when people do that,
when they pretend they're having a
conversation with you and really they're
trying out material.
Okay.
What's worse is when it's very obvious.
You know,
some people could actually get away with
it cause you're like telling the joke
and they think you know it's
funny but some people just,
you could tell they just doing bits.
There's a
dude I used to play pool
with and it was brutal.
He was a comic and he used to go
tell me if you think
there's anything in this,
no,
don't drop my head down.
He didn't have a whole lot of friends and
he was like really into his comedy and
he was one of those guys.
He was a decent comic but he wrote out
every fucking joke as he would say it on
stage.
So it never seemed like when he was on
stage it was really just up there fucking
around.
It always seemed like,
here's some material that I wrote today,
Dee Dee Dee.
And so he like holds me hostage
there while we're playing pool.
And while he says out the whole joke,
you know like literally,
have you ever noticed
like he gives me a hug
if you have noticed.
No Q motherfucker.
Did you just give me a,
have you ever noticed,
you ever notice?
I noticed a lot of shit dude.
You want to talk about other shit?
I noticed man,
that's the Pr,
that's the problem with comedy man.
There's like gay comedy,
but they're like the shitty
comedian is a pathetic figure.
Managed is such a rough mode of being man.
It's such a,
such a silly embarrassing existence.
What's the idea that you,
you command the attention of the crowd.
You are,
your voice is amplified.
Your,
there's a light spot put on
you and you are supposedly,
you know,
so entertaining and interesting that all
you have to do is talk and you're going
to grab the attention of all these
people in this room and you're requesting
this exorbitant amount of attention.
And it's because you claim to have this
skill and this skill is you're going to
elicit laughter.
Going to extract laughter
from the audience.
Yeah.
Good luck.
It was really weird lately.
If I have been noticing there's
this whole breed of comic,
uh,
open miker mostly,
but,
uh,
that,
that does their whole act,
but not once did you think no,
there's a joke there.
Meaning like,
like they're just talking and like the,
they're forgetting that this
is supposed to be funny.
Almost like they're almost saying a story
and when they're done with the story,
they expect you to clap it,
then you'd,
you know,
nothing in,
it was even a joke where it's like,
is that their sense of humor is that bad?
Or they just don't get
thorough conquers open?
Miker so you're,
you're just like,
that's like saying like,
how come this guy who,
uh,
you know,
doesn't know how to throw
a punch at all things.
He's going to be on the ultimate fighter.
You know,
you're,
you're just there.
They're not good.
They're in Compton.
It's so amazing that people
can be that bad though.
What's amazing is that
can be that bad forever.
I mean,
how many dudes you've ever
seen at the comedy store?
They've been doing standup for 10 plus
years doing open mics and they're still
like brutally so insane.
Like how do you use it for Gri?
You should progress like you're
talented in the opposite way.
The fact that you haven't gotten better
at all and you've been doing it for some
people 15 years,
I don't think you can get better
if you're not good at all.
I think,
you know,
there are some guys that get into comedy
that truly don't understand what comedy
is and they see other people
doing it and talking it,
but they're so socially unaware that they
don't know how they come off to other
people and they probably
don't have the tools,
the psychological tools,
the cognitive tools to really
objectively assess their own personality.
So they're never going
to be able to do right.
Literally are never going to be,
you have to have a certain amount
of awareness in order to do standup.
And there's a lot of
people that attempt it.
They just don't have that.
They don't have it.
And if you don't have it,
man,
you got to do,
there's something has to happen.
Dramatic.
You got to go to Mexico
and do Ibogaine Iowasca me,
something like that.
Yeah,
I blow.
Yeah.
The come back.
You literally have to
become a different person.
The person that you are is just you.
You what you have is like,
it's like I want to race in
the Formula One Grand Prix,
but I have a Toyota Camry.
What do you think I should
do while you're fucked?
Yeah,
just fucking cars go 250 miles an hour
and they're three inches off the ground.
And where,
what are you going to do?
You're not gonna,
you're not gonna do that.
You know you're not equipped for it.
You have to change your equipment,
you know
that's it.
That's what it takes.
The snake must shed its God
damn skin from time to time.
And this is the right phrase
friend.
We're,
you're all slow dude.
I'm the same dude.
Ah,
you know,
I've just,
this is kind of like a weird
off topic idea that I've had,
but I wanted to tell you about
it cause I had this weird,
cause you were a Catholic,
this whole thing is off topic.
Evan.
No,
we never say off the top of this bug
is off this script that we'd been
rehearsing for the last,
I was raised Catholic.
Yeah.
Um,
and in,
in,
in religion there's this idea of tithing
where you're supposed to get your 10%
of your income income to the church.
So dude,
I've started thinking about that and
I've started thinking like how fucking
interesting would your life get if you
decided to give 10% of your income,
not to the church,
but you decided to like give 10% of your
income to do like really cool things
for people randomly.
You know what I mean?
I see what you're saying.
Your own sort of the church offering.
Yeah.
But it's not no churches involved
or anything you'd just like,
cause like the man like to go back
to the idea of psychedelic states,
things that induce psychedelic states.
Fucking helping someone randomly that
doesn't expect you to like if you go out
and you think I'm going to go,
I'm not a big fan of giving money to
like people in front of seven 11 you were
like covered in sores.
I think that that's like kind of
like a way of killing somebody.
But like if you go out and have some
extra money and decided I'm going to do
something cool with this or you just try
to like convert your financial energy
and to some positive thing that you
randomly do for someone and you decide I'm
going to do this from two
to four o'clock today.
Right.
That puts you in the weirdest,
most psychedelic state and when you do
some random good thing for somebody,
dude,
it blows people's minds.
Like they freak the fuck out.
Like the look on their faces,
like what just happened to me because
everything is inverted and our society
towards the south,
everyone is always
thinking about themselves.
Everyone's always fixating on themselves.
If if for two hours you don't
fixate on yourself long enough to go
do some random fucking thing for somebody.
Dude,
it's trippy.
I definitely think that it
put an energy in towards,
you know,
any,
any sort of charitable notion,
anything where you re helping people.
It definitely is the,
the right kind of energy to
put out there in the world.
It definitely can induce,
you know,
a different state of mind,
a different state of being.
But if the charity thing,
which is great,
I mean anything is good like,
but when you know,
you call it and you give money to somebody
or you have some kind of fund that
you put money into the outstanding
I'm talking about like physically,
I know what you're saying.
Okay.
Yeah.
How many charitable,
I mean like going out and helping people.
I definitely agree.
I mean,
how many of these fucking organizations
keep getting busted charitable
organizations when you find out like,
oh,
the white club John Thing for Haiti and
you know that you find out they're all
stealing money and it's like,
it's always,
it's always some,
something like that was always going down,
doing random cool things for people.
It does,
uh,
it gives you like a definitely gives
you some sort of a weird charge.
You know,
when I gave away my
isolation tank on time,
um,
that was a,
one of the coolest things
I ever did because,
I mean this is fucking $8,000 a
piece of equipment and some dude,
I don't even know just,
and then bought salt.
Salt was like 1200 bucks and
then had it moved to his house,
you know,
I had to pay for a moving company and
then I had to pay for an installer to go
install it in his house.
I mean,
one of the fucking guy doesn't
even use it at bastard.
Yeah Man,
I'm,
I want to ask him for it back on.
Give it to you.
Do you have a place that it works out?
The best place to have it.
Perfect place for a day.
You need to get one.
It's his man cave.
Yeah.
We need to,
we need to get your fucking man cave.
I got a place right next to
a shower where it could just,
I could basically go right from the
flotation world needs Duncan Trussell to
have a fucking isolation tank.
God hear my prayer.
Really?
You need to mix horizon iPhone.
Yeah.
What do you,
what you are with,
um,
with a,
well you've got,
you've got a couple of
different projects going on,
but when one of these hits,
man,
when you get your first fat
check and we're going to get you,
if this guy won't give up the time,
I don't think this guy
wants to give up his tank.
I think he's getting,
he's going through a divorce now though.
So he might have to move the tank.
You might not have the
money to reset the tank up.
Right.
I'll store it for him.
I talked to him about it like a year
after I sent it to him and he's like,
yeah,
I hardly ever use it.
I'm like,
you fuck.
God damn happened to do it randomly.
Yeah,
but you know,
I figured anybody that was,
I mean he and the guy was like
a wannabe standup comedian.
He's like trying to be a comic.
It's like Jesus Christ,
dude,
I gave you a fucking doorway to the
universe and you don't open it and go
through it.
Every now and then.
He's got his old checks in there.
I bet there's no water in it.
He just puts all boxes in it.
I was thinking I would
have just built a shed.
I just build a shed
for a washer and dryer.
You know how easy it would have been.
Just a build a shed for that.
That would be,
would you have used it though?
I've never been in one,
so I'll probably say it.
I'd never been in one,
so probably.
But yeah,
but I've offered you to go
to the soothing solutions.
You've never gone to that.
Do you want to go to that?
Never made the call you
want when you want to do it,
I'll do it.
We'll set it up,
set it up.
Or you can go to float lab.
That's the best place to float.
Lab ones are on another
level they're got Craig,
if you're in a go to float lab.com
and look at what this guy's doing.
This guy was making these super
fucking thick stainless steel.
Insulated tanks isn't the greatest.
There is like the apple a flotation.
Yeah.
He's just a bad motherfucker.
He's like this crazy mad scientist dude.
He's like really into floating.
He's trying to invent some,
some new screen where you can watch.
It's the lowest amount of light is coming
through these LCD screens so you can
watch like documentaries inside the tank
and you can learn from it learn and it
helps you have like,
it defeats the purpose.
I think so,
but I'm not into it at all.
It's kind of interesting
information blasted.
Well,
that's what he's saying is
that when you don't have,
when you have an absence of sensory input,
you,
you can really absorb information
in a much faster rate.
And it totally makes sense on
paper because the whole idea,
I mean,
look,
it's very difficult to watch a movie if
there's jackhammers going on behind you.
It's distracting you.
You had a float tank that had a
interactive surface on the top of it,
so they can turn completely
dark if you want it to.
But if you want,
you could light the entire fucking
thing up with like the universe,
the Milky Way.
Uh,
I don't know.
It just blue sky or whatever,
just fucking Sanskrit versus from like
all the great scriptures flying on there.
It'd be incredible Sanskrit
versus when did you,
would you look at the translation?
Do you,
do you,
uh,
how long would it take to learn Sanskrit?
I like a 10 year project.
I think it would take a long fucking time,
but I don't know if
anybody would be into that.
I would think it would be you.
I'd love to just because it's
Sanskrit and and Tibetan.
When I'm on mushrooms and I start like
you close your eyes and you see those
weird symbols.
I see a gypsum and stuff.
See that's the thing and I always wonder,
these,
these symbols are seeing,
I always think Mayan looking thing.
I knew how to read this.
Would I be reading like some
kind of message here is this,
am I actually looking at
some kind of scripture?
You know what Mckenna believes?
Actually what he thought was
that when you do a psychedelic,
what you're doing is your taking part
in the experience of everyone else who's
also done that psychedelic.
That's why he,
we just described ketamine is such an
odd psychedelic because it seems like its
database of users was very,
very small,
so he said Ketamine felt like an
office building that was empty.
It would go in there and it's just
empty cubicles like where is everybody?
Whereas mushrooms you do it.
You're dealing with 10,000 years of
obsessive daily use by millions of people
over the world.
And a lot of those being the
Mayans mean a Mayans were heavily,
heavily into mushrooms.
You know,
when I was,
um,
in,
uh,
when I was in a,
and Eatsa and I went on a tour,
the guy that took me
on a god was a really,
really interesting guy.
He was a,
a local,
a university professor who also,
uh,
did guides,
like did tours and shit like that.
It's just really deep
into the history of it.
And he just openly talked
about the psychedelics,
like how they would take psychedelics and
they had all different rooms that they
would know,
practice different rituals in.
And it's well known that there was a deep,
deep history in Mexico of,
of psychedelic mushroom use.
So it's not surprising
that when you do mushrooms,
and especially if you do mushrooms
that you buy in California,
you know,
I mean,
you're,
you're probably getting the
same strains that the Mayans,
God,
I mean,
you're probably getting those
mock those Mexican mushrooms.
Yeah.
You see all sorts of Weird Mayan symbols.
It's almost like what you're doing is
you're somehow or another tapping into
there,
the past people,
psychedelic experiences.
Obviously this is all just,
what are we all going to go?
Each room's me,
US three,
we shouldn't do it and we should just
go fucking on the beach somewhere.
As long as they don't have psilocybin.
And then my love to eat mushrooms
that you guys silicide been,
what do you mean?
That's what makes you trick.
As long as they don't
have psilocybin in them.
I don't want you to Talki eating
mushrooms to 500 buildings by now.
At least the 3000 or police officers.
Yeah.
Tentatively listening with a notepad.
They just said they're going to the beach.
It's just as ridiculous that mushrooms
are illegal as Monsanto trying to,
to patent a pig.
It's just as ridiculous.
Yeah.
The fuck is one person going
to tell you that some spore of,
of,
of fucking plant,
a living organism that grow by the way,
which is actually closer to a
human than plants already here.
Yes.
You know,
spores are,
are,
are closer to Austin then
cause they eat organic matter.
Yeah.
But dude,
I mean how fucking crazy.
It's not just that someone feels okay,
like the enforcing the law if you eat
those fucking things that make you see
some kind of weird transcendental language
that the Mayans were trying to copy
down.
That's what I think.
I think they're seeing a
language and they're like,
all right,
this is the best way we can replicate
this weird language that we were seeing.
I think that's what happened.
It could be,
but yeah,
the think did something that
produces like that effect.
There are people right now in federal
fucking penitentiaries right now laying in
a car in a federal penitentiary listening
to fucking white area and resistance
murderers jerking off.
Oh,
just because you wanted to fucking
see the mothership for a second.
You're three doors down from a
guy who fixed it as six year old.
Fuck though.
How is that possible?
Well actually,
you know,
nonviolent drug offenders don't get
locked up in the same place as people at
fist six year olds.
But I know what you're saying.
Just the fact that
they're in a cage at all.
I mean,
maybe you do once you
get in there and they,
you know,
one of the fucking Hispanic guys wants a
fight with you and your stab him in the
neck and you know,
you want up getting a
murder wrap on top of it,
which happens.
Shit happens to nonviolent drug offenders.
They wind up getting much deeper,
uh,
penalties for something they do
while they're actually in prison
to my friend got a Dui,
went to fucking county jail.
His jaw was broken within six minutes.
It was like a Saturday night
and they were gang bangers.
They're yet had to take a piss.
They wouldn't let him get to the toilet.
He's like,
I gotta Piss.
And they just were like,
what'd you say?
What?
Boom broke his fucking jaw for what?
Cause he fucking drove from
a club after one extra beer.
That's insane for you shouldn't be
lumped up in the same group of people,
but you know,
then again,
what if your friend slammed into a
fucking car and killed someone's kid?
Well,
I mean,
obviously you don't know how drunk
he was and I'm just guessing.
But it's the same thing.
Yeah.
I knew she shouldn't
drive drunk and God knows,
like,
I'm not saying he won't do that again.
All right.
Saying that's not the,
yeah,
well I don't know.
What'd you get raped?
He shouldn't have had that beer.
Yeah,
that's what she get.
I guess that's what you get.
It's so fucked up,
man.
It's real.
I don't know.
I definitely think that people
should be penalized for,
for putting other people in danger
because they're drunk and responsible,
but when it comes to
things like mushrooms,
which comes to psychedelic
experiences and,
and the idea that you can make any sort
of plant that grows here or fungus that
grows here naturally,
it's a part of the ecosystem already.
Way before,
you know,
we invented this is fucking
completely ridiculous.
Especially when you look at all the stuff
that is legal and all the stuff that
can kill you and all this stuff
that you could buy at any store.
It's completely silly.
It's not,
there's no logic behind it.
It's not like this is
like a rational decision,
like you're obviously deciding
what I can and can't do.
You're deciding what kind of
experiences I have and you're,
there's no science behind it.
This is not 1950 you can't pull
some McCarthyism bullshit on me.
I can get online and I can say,
well look,
no one's died from Silva Simon.
How come silicide means illegal?
Well,
look here,
I can show you a thousand different
people that will tell you that.
You know,
they've got over
posttraumatic stress disorder.
They've gotten over,
you know addiction's.
They've gotten over all these things
because of psychedelic experiences.
When you're telling me that it's illegal,
you're telling me that it's,
it's bad.
Why is it bad?
Here's the deal with anything.
Whenever there's something that people
can benefit from and people have all
these stories about and people,
there's,
there's an area to explore and someone's
keeping you from doing that and trying
to lock you in jail.
If you do do that,
they're the fucking criminal.
The monsters.
They're the monsters.
They are the fucking
criminals of the human race.
You or point,
you were putting a crime on people.
You are literally stopping
people from evolving.
Yup.
That it,
the fucking demon stopped doing it.
Dunkin.
I like to put people in jail.
Dunkin's all about constricting.
I love it.
There's nothing I love more than
having a mushroom addict in the back.
We're going to have to explore it.
Ball gags and whips
someday with you diapers.
You remember why the F
do you remember coming up and saying that?
That's hilarious.
Ball gags dog.
Right?
Just kidding.
I won't say,
Hey,
I,
we talked to Steve o today and he,
he's completely sober now.
He stopped smoking cigarettes.
Stop drinking.
He was doing,
he said he was doing so much drugs
the last couple of years of his life.
There was people walking around
his house that didn't exist.
That's how bad it got,
but now he just quit everything in and
now is Vegan and isn't that crazy to you
to think that that somebody
that gets an a toit was shit,
it's still concerned about his health,
that he's eating Vegan
and not on anything?
Well,
yes,
he's probably realizing how
silly his life was and he's like,
you know,
putting himself back in line.
It's like,
but what's the logical step to put
yourself as far in line as you can and go
vegetarian and Vegan.
There's a guy named John Fitch that
fought and this last UFC and he went,
he had a Vegan diet and I
thought was really interesting.
I wanted to see how he,
did he want to win and you beat Bj Penn?
It was sort of,
no,
I'm sorry it didn't beat Bj Penn.
He was a draw,
but he won.
The final round is cardio was really good.
It was really solid.
He was talking to miles.
Cardio is like off the charts now,
you know.
But the [inaudible] they
just have to refight.
I don't know.
They have to decide now.
They have to figure out
what the fuck to do,
you know,
because uh,
this was for the number one
contender spot and you know,
fish is still pushing,
you know,
after the post fight interview,
his coach was like,
you know,
ask for a title shot ever been.
And I'm like,
mom,
you can't ask for a title shot
after you get off of a draw.
It's just like too tough to sell.
What did you think was
going on with that fight?
Who Do you think draw could be a expected?
Depends on how you score.
The third round,
the third round was pretty decisive
victory for Fitch and some people thought
that was a ten eight round.
You know,
I'm not really,
it depends on how you use ten eight
rounds because I the the ten eight round,
the system that they use now,
I think it's like they don't
give out enough ten eight rounds,
but you have to decide when is it a ten
eight round when you're inside a guys
guard and he just punched him
to the body into the head.
I'm not sure if that's a ten eight round.
I could see it argued.
But Bj,
I thought one the first
two rounds because then,
but those were very close to,
I could see it argued
that pitched it to um,
Fitch one,
one of them because um,
you know,
Bj got his back,
PJ took them down,
Bj got us back,
but then he lost position
and Fitch got on top of them.
So the question is like,
well,
what is,
what's worth more?
Is it worth more to take a guy down and
to get a dominant position where you're
close to finishing a fight but then
losing it and getting reversed and wind up
being your guard with the guy
on top of you throwing punches.
Is that better or is it
better to take the guy's back?
What's worth more on points?
Well,
that's a subjective thing,
you know,
so it's tricky.
I could see that.
I could see the first two rounds
score for Bj and I could see,
I could see someone scoring one of
them for Fitch and I can also see the,
the second,
the third round rather being
ten eight so I could see a draw.
We were split two and
when we were watching it,
watching it,
it's tricky man.
It's tricky.
Mean Bj is a bad motherfucker,
but he's,
he's small for that weight class.
You know when he's fighting,
he's weighing one 66 with his pants
on and he's fighting Fitch who,
but this is the thing about Fitch.
The reason why I brought this up,
he was at one point in time,
like 200 pounds,
he would cut down to one 70 but now
he's like all organic and Vegan and he's
wearing around one 80 which is really
light for him and then dropping a little
weight but it's cardio is
like way better now too.
I've entertained trying like a
serious vegan diet for a while,
but you know I heard like Travis Barker
after he crashed in that plane and he
had to get skin grafts and shit like that.
They didn't take until he started eating
meat and he like stopped being a Vegan
in his recovery from that again,
he was a,
he was a Vegan before that and then you
know when he started eating red meat
then all of a sudden like his
healing like went through the roof.
Whenever I eat vegan food
and a Vegan restaurant,
I fucking love it.
Swingers.
I could make this myself.
I wouldn't want to,
I wouldn't care about,
well you could make it yourself easily.
It's a pain in the ass.
Pain in the ass.
I
could be wrong with our friend.
When when I dated her it was like having
to go to certain restaurants having to
do all this bullshit.
She's not even a Vegan anymore now.
Yeah.
She eats Vegan here and there but she's,
she gets me just fucking
filled with hormones right now.
Is it mostly just kidding?
Some meters?
Yeah.
It depends on where you're getting it.
Free Range.
You want free range,
organic meat and that
you want grass fed too.
I like gray.
I prefer the taste of grass fed is a
discussion that Ari and I actually had on
the podcast on a plane.
The A,
the difference between grass
fed and grain fed beef.
Beef is not,
it's not natural for
them to beat and grain.
They're not supposed to eat corn.
We give them corn because
it makes them fat as fuck,
which makes the meat so delicious and
tender when you cook it because there's
all this fat bubbling up
inside of it and you know,
and melting and it just gets awesome.
Like a big fat fucking grain fed steak.
You know,
it's just so just melts in your mouth.
But the reality is they're
supposed to be eating grass.
And when you,
you taste grass fed beef,
it has a distinctly different flavor.
I prefer it,
but I like game.
I like eating.
Like I like,
I like venison and elk.
I like eating like those meets,
I have my theories about that shit.
I feel like anything that's tough
to catch is easy or tough to catch,
whether is really good for you
and things that are easy to catch.
Like cows,
you can just walk right up to account,
shoot him in the fucking head.
They're stupid.
You know,
like you'll shoot account ahead and a cow
right next to him alert and he doesn't
even freak out and go holy fuck.
But like you try to shoot a pig,
pigs will run from you.
Man.
Pigs,
you know like,
and wild pigs like wild boar.
Very good for you.
How's her fucking sweet creatures?
Yeah,
well they're,
they're cows.
There's their cattle,
you know,
I mean the idea of cattle
like being like at our mercy,
you know,
like,
like
no,
they're like,
you know like in India how
like they worship cows.
So in India like in the streets or these
cows that have just been being petted
by people like dogs,
they are fucking sweet.
Don't you think?
No,
the,
that docile behavior has been engineered
through three years of breeding for,
for them to be,
you know,
farm animals for them to be used while
be so unnatural thing for people to just
walk right up to an animal
and be able to pet it.
People are creepy fucks,
you know?
I mean you have to engineer
an animal to be that docile,
you know,
like how long relationship
with humans for sure.
Yeah.
Wild cows and shit like that.
They don't have that sort of,
I mean there's other wild cows.
What the fuck am I doing here guys?
There must've been at some point
in time it must've been a wild,
there still is what?
Cows are so valuable.
Very few of them are wild,
right?
No,
no.
Catherine valuable.
Are they like,
is there like weight or
styles are very valuable,
really a lot of money
that's worth a lot of money.
Of course,
man,
steak cows are a dime a dozen much.
Would it cost to buy a cow?
It's a good question.
I think.
Look it up,
man.
Love to do that,
I would love to have my own farm someday
and just have animals that you know,
you know what they're feeding.
You know what you're feeding them,
rather,
you know if you're going to eat them,
you know how they're treated.
You know that it's all humane
dude.
I think about that.
My,
that my dream idea of that,
which is like this crazy plays
out in the woods with solar panels
where where the majority of
your electricity or all of
it is coming from the sun
and you're feeding yourself from
this place that's feasible here.
Yeah,
it's feasible,
but it's like so like so
much work to run a farm.
It's insane.
It's not like either or either you have
like people working for you and doing it
or if you're involved in it,
you're just,
there's no stairs.
You just work all day and sleep and
you wake up and work all day and sleep.
Yeah,
you,
you bud.
You can be self sustaining,
which is very,
you know,
rewarding for a lot of pieces.
That idea.
Ideally you grow all your own food,
grow your own vegetables and you
grow your own animals as well.
But yeah,
you could hire a few people to,
to run at me if you just wanted
a farm only for your families.
Sustenance.
You know,
that's kind of an interesting theory.
an interesting sort of a,
a concept,
you know,
set up a farm where all the vegetables
that you grow or vegetables that you eat
and then I guess you know
in the wintertime you can
them or something or you
have a greenhouse or
something you can't know.
Cows are about a thousand bucks,
1000 bucks for a cow.
So,
so it's a bargain and what
all the meat on that thing,
either by two cows or buy the new Mac
book out fucking new Mac book all the way
you guys lose and on this cause
you guys are fucking goofy.
Mac heads as our mind
iPad two and two days.
What is the nude was the
deal with these Mac books?
He goes,
they look amazing.
Well,
the biggest thing is the new technology,
the thunderbolt technology,
which is like 10 gigabytes per second.
The ball.
This is a phone call,
the thunderbolt two,
the child,
now that
it's 10 gigabytes per second.
So what that means is live like you're
pretty much going to be able to hook up
an external hard drive and edit HD video
easily and run multiple streams of,
you know,
it's going to help editing video editing
and transferring files nowadays when
you went to backup your
computer 10 gigabytes a second,
come on.
That's credible.
Insane.
And it has HD video cameras now.
Also bigger solid state
drive you can get up to,
what was it?
Everybody 50 thank you.
Got sponsored by Mack.
Well,
well they already do.
We use laptops that have
the big apple logo on.
It was like one of the
[inaudible] tried to sponsor us.
It was like asking like this apple boom,
you guys drove up a lot.
I wish apple please sponsor us.
But it was like quad cores.
That's 50 times faster than
the last last bit of Mac books.
50 Times.
Yeah.
And some of the early benchmarks are
showing anywhere from the 13 inch model
being about 12% faster.
Two to up to 53% faster.
Oh,
okay.
That's not 50 times.
I'm sorry.
50% 50% percent.
Sorry.
Jesus,
Quad Core,
double core quad core.
That's pretty interesting.
So that would be what you would need if
you were doing video rendering and shit
like that.
But for most people,
what the fuck?
It was just a matter of transferring even,
I mean,
have you noticed even,
I don't know on your laptop,
but I know that this one like fucking
youtube or youtube videos or any kind of
HD video still is struggling.
Even though this is a pretty fast laptop,
it's still struggles.
So the graphics card,
right.
So it's mostly the graphics card
and in just the fucking flash and
the video card that needs new ones have
video cards up to one gigabyte now,
which is crazy.
And the switch from the video,
which has been having a lot of
problems with the Mac books lately,
uh,
with an overheating
and problems with them.
Now they switched back to a,
a AMD or,
or whatever.
So this is interesting to me is
exciting but not that exciting.
I need some new shit.
I need,
I need some next level shit.
This transferring gigabytes real quick.
That's all good and everything like that.
But what is the next thing that a fucking
computer's going to do that's really
going to blow you away?
That's going to do that?
I think if we're going more
towards tablet more for Jackson,
quantum computing,
no,
it's that fucking,
um,
the computer that just
beat people at jeopardy.
Yeah,
no,
seriously.
You know,
it used to be like a computer that could
play chess and beat people was a big
deal.
Now everyone has a computer
that can be you at chess,
right?
Eventually.
Like the next thing you're talking about
is like interactive surfaces where you
tell it exactly what you want.
I'm actually more excited about this
iPad to announcement March 2nd which is
supposedly going to have cameras
in the front and back pretty soon.
That's going to change the whole thing
with being able to do facetime and
watching you stream.
Now you can be able to
use string from your team.
Hi Pat,
this is,
this is what's really
trippy quantum computing.
That's the really weird shit because
first of all try to wrap your head around
what a quantum computer really is.
You have to really kind of understand
what the idea behind quantum mechanics and
what it basically is is a,
this is how it's listed in Wikipedia.
A device for computation that makes
direct use of quantum mechanical phenomena
such as super position and entanglement.
And if you don't know what that means,
superposition means that an object can
be both moving and still at the same
time.
I mean the,
the,
the idea of quantum mechanics you get
into like that's weird Voodoo Shit.
Things that particles that subatomic
particles at blink in and out of existence
and the idea of,
you know,
it being able to be effected by the user.
I mean those are all
quantum mechanical ideas,
quantum entanglement because that
really is Voodoo shit that's like,
that's a computer quantum
entanglement is as I understand it,
is the idea that if you take two particles
and put them together and then move
them apart,
right.
They still are somehow connected and
you can transfer information down that
line.
It's one of those things
where I talk about it.
I say what I've heard said,
but I don't know what it means.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm talking about super positions
and I'm talking about entanglement and
I'm saying all those things,
but I mean what,
what,
you know,
all I'm doing is making the
right noises with my mouth.
You know,
my brain barely makes the connection
to what the fuck that screw the mind.
Yeah.
Connection is just this rudimentary thing
where I think of like to round things
that have what appear to be a really
long hair attaching them or something.
Like when you like the idea that you
did things just kind of like have some
invisible or tiny uh,
relationship that just stretches apart.
But the,
the reason I say that it's Voodoo or
witchcraft is cause it's like Rosemary's
baby who remember the guy
called and he was missing his,
like
one of the things which is are always
trying to do is deal a little piece of you
get your hair and quantum entanglements.
True.
Then that would mean that there's some
connection between you and the thing that
came from you did,
they could start shooting
bad energy down that line.
Whoa.
Holy Shit
Real.
They just didn't have the words for it.
I always thought about Alchemy,
like the idea of alchemy.
Like what,
you know when people are trying to make
gold at a lead and using magic and all
sorts of different things,
like where is it?
What's,
what's that?
Is that,
is that,
I mean if,
if we really do break down things as
far as their elemental structure and we
really under,
is it possible to turn
lead into gold Sunday?
Is someone going to be able to adjust,
you know,
what,
what the,
the molecules that the differentiate
between gold and lead and platinum and
silver,
is that possible?
Or you can do it.
I mean,
there are like the three d printers,
just sort of a diamonds.
It's,
that's like you're,
you're smashing something with intense
pressure and creating a new thing with
it,
but you're not turning
something into something.
It's not,
it's like a natural sort of,
uh,
men are mo fos metamorphoses right.
Doesn't that make sense?
Yeah.
Well,
because we know like what the,
the chain reaction that causes diamonds,
we or the chemical reaction that pressure
and carbon and millions of years or
you know,
some crazy fucking thing that the
Russians event that makes diamonds out of
nothing.
Well,
have you ever heard the idea that coal,
that alchemy was
code for a secret society that was trying
to teach people to become enlightened
through science and that the idea,
yeah,
lead into gold,
the ID of the transmutation
of lead into gold.
They didn't really,
even though that it
was a focus of alchemy,
there was a deeper level,
which is the idea that they're talking
about the transformation of the human
consciousness from going to a useless,
empty robotic state to a fully realized,
say like,
and once you go to that state,
you don't care if something's gold.
You don't care about the material.
Universe doesn't mean anything anymore.
I'd never heard that before.
I'd always heard it just described as
someone trying to manipulate one form of
matter to turn into
something more valuable.
Great.
Yeah.
Movie by this guy,
and it's fucking trippy,
dude.
You know Joe to Roskie is,
you ever heard of him?
No.
How to say his name?
Darius Kiyota.
Roski.
Oh,
dude.
Jay.
Oh,
Joe.
I'm going to spell it wrong.
What's his last name?
Joe To Roskie was super last name.
[inaudible] Honjo Joe to
Roskie and there's a book,
a movie that he made
called the Holy Mountain.
Alejandro Jodorowsky.
Yeah.
Look Up Alejandro Jersey.
Uh,
w.
S K y.
John Lennon paid for the
movie the Holy Mountain,
but like check it out.
It was like at the time he had
this teacher was telling him,
well,
why you're making this movie?
Just take as much LSD as you can
and it always sound advice.
Check it out.
It's on youtube.
There's like a part of your
website that has all these movies.
You recommend all this shit because
you always bring out this crazy shit.
I have no way,
dude,
you should totally have that.
I should have a little list there.
Something really should
turn on your Amazon.
You should.
Yeah.
Well you,
you need to be more active
with your web presence fell on.
Yeah.
You,
I mean website cast and I tweet.
Yeah,
but your website,
which would be the what?
I used to do a lot more work on it now
until I've been working on this book.
I haven't been really riding.
I got asthma.
I do.
I love your website by the way.
I put it on a couple of
computers at apple the other day.
Homepage to visit the artistic terrorism?
No,
it's Duncan trussell.com used to have
the other one artist terrorism got yanked
from the by me from some
fucking Russian punks do it.
And then the next thing I knew
I went to artistic terrorism.
It's like some Russian site,
you can't get it back now it's gone.
Is that how it works the way?
It's pretty easy for that
to happen that just have,
that happens all the time.
A lot of people get like
conscious and gets their hosting.
So again,
that sounds like a name.
The guy who drowned
himself in the bathtub,
we'll come up with [inaudible]
and that was just a long time ago.
That was when I worked
at the comedy store.
Do you remember when you worked at
the comedy store and we used to,
I used to call you up and we'd have long
ass fucking crazy conversations while
you were working there.
That's how he got to be friends.
Yeah.
Well,
I used to know Dunkin from Dunkin
hanging out there and then Dunkin started
working for the store and I would call
up and dug it and I would have long
fucking bizarre conversations
that would last for hours.
While you were,
while you were working.
Pretty much this would happen
over the phone and dunking.
Here's proof that Dunkin practices what
he preaches when he was working at the
comedy store.
That's when the Pauly shore reality
show came around and everybody else went
along with it and is like,
you know what,
I don't want to be a part
of this and you quit.
I quit.
And you didn't have an option.
I didn't want to be on that show.
Well man,
what,
what started happening is like,
it seemed like,
you know,
he was talking about trying
to make a show happen and uh,
you know,
and then the show started happening
for real and all of a sudden I couldn't
sleep at night and I
was grinding my teeth.
Cause the idea of having to be on
this reality show and like I was,
I would wake up and I,
my teeth grinding and I'd be like,
oh,
and this fucking feeling
that pit of my stomach.
Like,
oh no,
this is it.
This is how you're going to,
cause I didn't know at
the time I was like,
fuck this.
What if the show takes off?
What if you're the,
you're the,
you're the fucking guy who works
with poly at the comedy store.
You're,
you're not a comedian.
You're just the guy behind a desk.
Answering the phone from Mitzi was
just like the most humiliating.
It would have been the worst thing ever.
Yeah.
That was cool that he did.
You've really,
uh,
you really like,
you know,
you,
you had a reaction to it.
A very strong reaction,
which a lot of people wouldn't because
this is an opportunity for you to get on
television,
on TV.
Also,
I got to get on TV.
I just got to get in front
of those cameras at all.
Do you think you could
have done for your factor?
What do you mean?
If someone came up to
you and said,
Hey Dunkin,
we have this show,
we want you to host fear factor.
It's going to be this network,
a reality show.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I don't think that would have been your,
I know you might not have done it.
You're,
you're a weird dude man.
You might have walked away from me.
Blame the difference between,
and by the way,
cause I do not want to come off like
I'm some kind of like a saint or self
righteous,
like super like my art.
What does it take?
Right.
It wasn't just any
reality show by the way.
You had worked there and saw the toxic
environment dealing with for a long time
and then saw that the most toxic
of all was in control of this,
this sort of project and it was going
down all the wrong paths and you know,
you made it a conscious too,
Susan.
I needed a way the fuck out of that job.
It was a desk job and like yeah,
you know,
I needed to get the fuck out.
And it was just like,
it seemed like a lot of things
were aligning at the same time.
They gave me a way to move on
instead of a continuing in a,
in this job that,
by the way,
it was like a job where I was tired of it.
The guy who's the current
talent coordinator was
obviously really into the idea
of having that job.
Like for him,
he wanted to do it,
whereas for me,
it was like,
it had gotten to the point where I
wasn't inspired by it and it was,
this seem like to continue on would be
the ultimate hypocrisy and would be a
shitty move on
every single.
That's interesting because a lot of
people would have never thought about that
way.
They would've thought,
well,
here's an opportunity.
I mean,
honestly meet me personally,
I probably would have
thought about it and said,
well,
you know,
if I was working there,
at least I'll get on television,
this will give me an opportunity to,
you know,
maybe branch off and do other things,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
man,
there's a,
I've got a really like weird hang up,
uh,
when it comes to performance,
which is that I think that people,
if they're performing for
something that's making money,
deserve to get paid for it.
And so when I do our comedy
show at the cemetery Thursday,
we pay,
oh yeah,
it's this Thursday.
We pay our comedians.
Uh,
we pay everyone who performs
and if I'm shooting something,
even if it's something that,
uh,
I'm not getting paid for,
if someone comes in is in
a sketch I come up with,
I pay them like I give them money because
they drove out there and gave me their
time and they fucking deserve it.
Cause that's,
I believe that you should
be compensated a for art.
I think that it's one of
the highest things ever.
So another thing that was a little off
putting about that show is that I was
clearly going to white,
not,
it wasn't just like they were going
to film me at my desk doing my job.
It was like they wanted to
create a heightened reality.
You know what I mean?
Which one of you to fake
shit and follow a script.
So I brought,
it was a bad school,
so I said,
you know,
well what?
What did well,
I'm an eat for one.
I was,
I was even then,
I was in a,
after I was in a actors' union.
It's like,
so wait a minute,
you're not going to pay me for acting.
Don't like,
I'm you ha you have to like you,
we,
I get caught.
I know that you're making money.
Anyone who's acting in spending their
time involved in this thing should be
getting paid.
They should get a little piece,
but then you weren't going to get paid.
The producer had said to me,
absolutely not.
No Way.
This is a documentary.
We're shooting a documentary.
You're,
you're not.
There's no,
that's fucked up.
There's no payment.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
What?
W who is the producer?
Whoever was producing two hands,
they literally told you that you're going
to be on the show and not get paid at
all.
All.
Yeah.
So you were going to be on TV making your
salary from the comedy store that you
go,
Whoa,
I didn't know that.
what
bunch of cunts.
I did not know that at all.
Yeah,
so that would,
that is that,
does that surprise you given the toxic
environment that we were talking about,
what you do,
how about a comics opening for him and
not getting paid and all sorts of the
Shit Day you're doing
it for the store buddy?
Well,
no,
that's the C and that's the,
the the,
the problem about that attitude,
uh,
which is in so many
different aspects of society,
which is where the artist is given the
impression that they are lucky to be
doing there are in a certain place.
Yes.
That is fucking satanism.
That is not how it works,
man.
It's like I don't care what
the fucking place is the are,
if it's a place that's making money
and generating money off the artist,
the artist,
is it the top of the fucking pyramid,
right.
Actually this logic,
if there's a fucking guy who
makes beautiful cabinets,
the most beautiful cabinets in the world,
that guy is not going to be like,
man,
I am so lucky to be in this workshop
where they let me make these cabinets.
No,
the,
the comedy store is the worst case example
of a place that thinks it's the star,
the place that thinks it's,
what's it called?
Let me just say it's changed a lot.
Like,
yeah,
it has,
I have to stick up for
the place because I,
um,
uh,
well,
but I go up there regularly and I,
uh,
the climate is kind of took it back.
Comics kind of take it back,
the place possible.
Honestly,
the places on the Dean's
still the manager.
No,
I've never seen him there anymore.
She's undergone a fucking,
a geologic shift.
They're putting on really
good acts right now.
It's fucking packed all the time.
It's got a really exciting,
good vibe there.
And that period of stagnation
and weirdness that were
new when with which made
you,
which drove you out,
that's long gone.
Yeah.
Really?
What do you think killed that man?
So you're not being around anymore.
Uh,
I wouldn't,
I changed it.
I just still welcome to go there.
Right man.
See Ya.
Yeah.
He can still go there and I don't know,
but it's only once.
I don't,
I think he has to call in
now where he be getting,
I think Sarah Silverman
just went up there.
She's there all the time.
Chappelle's every time
I go in there I'm like,
what the fuck?
It's generally just like burgeoning,
like you know what it seems like,
it seems like the management kind of
took a step a couple steps back or that
they were told to or that,
that they just kind of got bored of
trying to be because now seems like really
you just see
the comics,
the comics are
just all,
that's always best case scenario,
you know,
um,
this talk about people getting paid.
Here's another interesting topic that I
want to bring up to you and we'll just
end on this because we've
been going on forever.
There's a lot of podcasts that are doing
podcasts now and find a live audiences
and it's a way of generating
revenue for the podcast.
But they're not paying the people
that are guests on the podcast,
you know?
And,
uh,
one invited me,
and I'm not going to name any names,
but invited me to go and be on one
of their podcasts in front of a live
audience.
And I said,
he know,
you know what?
No one's picketing paid you.
Your,
you're going to do,
someone's going to drive an hour away.
And I've done this before,
by the way,
because I just,
you know,
it's kind of a,
uh,
you know,
it's an opportunity to go
and be on something and,
you know,
have some fun and you know,
and network with all these other
people that are doing these things.
But at a certain point in time,
I'd be like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
How much do you charge?
There's costs 20 bucks to get in,
or 30 bucks to get in.
And you've got 500 people in here.
What's going on here?
Is this a comedy show?
Because if it's a comedy show
that it makes sense that,
you know,
you're the headliner,
but you have to pay the opening act.
You gotta pay the Middle Act,
you've got to pay everyone
who performs on your show.
You know,
it's a note that the bandwidth though,
that podcasts have been
racking up on some people.
Like what was Adam Carolla saying?
Navy is paying up to $5,000 a month.
You said 10,000,
$10,000 a month.
I mean,
that Shit's real shit,
man.
That fucking bandwidth podcast,
we'll usually about 100 megabytes each.
He Times that by law,
I don't know,
a couple of hundred thousand people.
That's ridiculous.
But you know what?
Yes.
What,
um,
the,
you know,
how much does it benefit those
comics to be on the show?
It benefits them a bit,
but it definitely benefits the person
who's running the podcast to have a,
a star on their podcasts.
You know,
if you're going to do it
in front of a live on it.
So it's a weird situation right now.
It's like,
it's a weird dynamic and almost feels
like we need a union to step in.
It's like,
what's,
I mean,
how can you do that?
There's just a basic logic,
uh,
that should go behind.
If you're making a show,
if you're producing a show,
there's just a basic logic,
the basic logic gates that the
performers are the heart of the show.
If you're making money,
you have to compensate them.
That's just logic.
You're not doing them a favor
by letting them perform,
but you are kind of a
little bit because you're,
you know,
you're,
you're giving them exposure.
Made me think about every
time you come on this show,
I mean this show,
obviously we're not getting paid
except for the sponsor and the sponsor.
Basically it's all gone.
I mean the sponsor pays for bandwidth
and Brian and a bunch of other things and
it's all gone.
But you,
you get on a show like
this and for sure it,
it elevates you and makes
people aware of you.
But then on the other hand,
the show's way better
when you're on like it,
it benefits us too.
Like Dan,
I used to bother me a lot about like
radio shows were like someone would say
something douchey about someone.
The person wouldn't want
to do the show anymore.
And they would say,
hey,
didn't we help you?
Didn't we help you out?
Like,
yeah,
but you got to,
you can look at it that way.
But it also look at it like you need to
have funny people on your shelf or your
show to be good.
He should be happy.
They go on it.
Shouldn't you know that the devil,
here's the insurance man,
this show for one.
I've made a fortune and
flashlights fucking many.
Ah,
and the other thing about it is that,
um,
we're friends and it's like,
it's,
there's no sense of like,
you're lucky to be here.
This is the best venue for you though,
man.
This is the best,
the,
the best opportunity that people
have ever had to get a look at.
What's special about you and weird about
you to have these long ass two and a
half plus our conversations,
we're get into weird depth
about chess a little,
but people get a chance to
see your personality and
the way you would never get
exposed to on a talk show or there's
no way in some seven minute clip on,
you know,
name the show.
You know,
I don't know when Jimmy Fallon,
the name,
whatever the show is it any,
any of those shows?
What are you gonna do?
You're gonna talk about something for
seven minutes and sitting at the desk and
come up with a cup of coffee.
Don't know people.
You know the way people know
us from doing this show the,
they know you in a deep,
deep way that really there's no other
opportunity to get this close to people
does close to the workings of the mind.
Dude,
I have fucking still ongoing conversations
happening on Facebook with people
from this podcast.
He like,
I'll tell them something crazy and then
they'll email me like the most insane
subversive fucking video or
just like really crazy shit.
Sometimes I can't go on Facebook if
I'm to stone because I'll start getting
paranoid because there'll be some like
heavy duty weird fucking shit up there.
Yeah.
Well you know what ma'am,
this is what's going on.
You know,
But we are connecting with like minded
people in a way that's never been
available before and
it's starting a network.
You know,
it's not just a network with podcasts,
with the death squad podcast
and years of lavender hour,
you know,
[inaudible] that.
But it's also a network with all these
fucking people on Facebook and all these
people on Twitter and these people that
I met in Australia that came to the show
and these people that are,
I've got to show this weekend or
this week rather a Wednesday night.
Yeah,
Wednesday night.
I'm at the Louisville,
Kentucky Improv.
That's my next gig.
And that's another one.
This is all promoted just
strictly straight from,
from Twitter.
You're going to know on there,
man,
I'm sure we're going to have fun.
We have fun everywhere.
And that's the deal.
I mean,
I have fun in Australia,
I have fun.
We,
we were bringing these people all together
and people are getting connected and
there's a movement going on and it's,
yeah,
there's a movement of the mind.
There's,
this is an opportunity for people to
find and connect with likeminded people
about things that they
thought were interesting.
That fucking was not
available just a year ago.
Right.
You know,
it was not available two
years ago or three years ago.
It's like this new,
this new thought,
this new hive mind that's being created.
And it's not,
I'm not,
I'm not taking responsibility for it.
It's,
it's creating itself.
It's always been things that I've always
been interested and it's always been
things that you've always
been interested in.
It's refining and altering the way that
I think about the world because I'll say
yes,
I'll obviously say some pretty stupid
shit that I haven't thought about and I'll
get an email or,
or,
or five Facebook messages
correcting whatever fact.
Uh,
and usually very politely,
usually.
Yeah,
very politely.
And it's just like,
oh,
okay,
well,
and then and then I'll find myself walking
the next day,
like walking my dog and just
thinking about that that way,
that then my new version of the uniform.
Absolutely.
And that's that.
That's the evolution.
Yes.
It's ours.
It's theirs.
It's we,
you know,
I've,
I've said this many times that I've
talked to a bunch of people that have said
they don't know anybody like us.
They don't ever have the chance to
have these opportunities to have these
conversations with people
that are near them,
but now they get to sit in
on these conversations and
it's changing the way they
think.
What changes the way I think too,
because we're having these conversations
on a really regular basis where we know
we're broadcasting them,
so we know a lot of the
shit we say we have to be,
we have to check it and
you have to correct it.
We have to do some Google searching,
we have to consider our options,
consider the the contrary argument,
and then we'll get all sorts
of different cool comments and,
and different links and different things.
Here's another thing that they're
doing on my message board.
Every time there's a podcast,
they'll start a thread where they
analyze the podcast as it goes along,
and then they'll put
links up and videos up to,
we're talking about.
It's fucking amazing,
man.
And it's all natural.
It's all just a natural,
uh,
correct.
It's all just,
it's just grown out of interest and,
and,
and it spreads and then people contribute
to it and then it gets larger and
larger.
I mean,
it really is.
There's a hive mind.
It's going on bitches.
It's going on right now.
And that's what we're gonna do.
Can I,
can I say once something
I've got coming up?
Can I have no,
no plugs.
Capitalism.
Boy,
comedy is dead.
Yes.
When is it,
is Thursday?
Thursday we kept with gay
this gate and it's out.
It's out a funeral,
by the way.
Did it not a role,
excuse me,
cemetery.
How many is that?
Is it the holiday?
Well,
no,
not ever live funeral.
And every,
occasionally someone will die on stage.
It's in,
it's in a masonic lodge at the
Hollywood forever cemetery.
Uh,
and this was the address
6,000 Santa Monica Boulevard.
And we've got Neil hamburger.
Yes.
You haven't seen him,
you have to see him.
But this guy I'm really excited about.
We have Mary Lynn Rice Cub from 24.
Yeah.
And we've got a,
this guy I'm seeking for that
book I just gave you this,
you said read that on stage.
Ah,
there's a,
uh,
a guy named caisters Stross.
He's the Yoyo Guy who
invaded all these uh,
uh,
TVs.
Oh,
I saw that.
And he's going to be performing on,
explain that real quick.
This would be the end.
It's because this guy,
he went on these shows,
he pretended that he knows how
to do the Yo Yo yo for kids.
You did a character on
these morning shows.
He apparently you could just send them
a letter and Sam traveling through
schools doing environmental
lessons and using Yoyos to do it.
And it kind of seems like a nice,
good feel.
Good story.
And so they invite him,
man,
he's wearing this ridiculous outfit.
He's a,
uh,
he's a a character actor on the level
within like when Kaufman would do his
stuff,
he's that fucking good and he's this
adult guy who comes on stage with the Yoyo
Eric and doesn't really get to the Yoyo.
They finally ended up having
to ask him to do it every day
and every time they ask him to do it,
something awful goes wrong.
The Yoyo breaks,
he can't Yo yo.
And he just leaves them
hanging everything.
Well,
it's awkward and they want
to like make him feel better,
but he's like each time,
like he like he's clearly like out of it.
You,
you,
it,
it's all on youtube.
What's his name again?
Hey straws.
S S t.
R.
A.
S.
The Yoyo Guy just looked at a
straws like case dress did letter k.
K?
Yeah,
the letterK and then s.
Yeah.
And what is he going to do with your show?
He's got a show based around
the character is going to,
his character will be there and
he does a Yoyo show for everybody.
So it's basically the same thing.
It's like kind of,
well,
you don't know,
right?
Well,
no,
I saw him doing it as
you've been doing standard,
right?
Or is he just doing this kind
of weird performance art thing?
Performance art.
How long have you been doing it?
Uh,
he's obviously been doing some form of
character comedy for a while because he's
too good at it to not have fucking
practice or it could be crazy.
Right.
He's out.
Met Him.
He's not,
he's a super nice guy.
He's like a really cool drugs.
No Charlie Sheen.
Do you wanna hear a little bit over?
Yeah.
What us now we're done.
It's this fucking thing.
Been Gone for three hours.
Dot.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Duncan Trussell for coming on.
You're the man.
You're always,
no,
I shouldn't even say you're the man.
You're fascinating.
Fascinating human being.
And one of my best friends
and I'm honored that you know,
you can be my friend and
come on the podcast here.
Yes.
Coolest fucking,
it's awesome having you on here.
And lavender hour.
You can download off iTunes and a,
you guys have a website,
lavender,
lavender.com and it's a hymn and Natasha
Look Gero Gero zero and it's a very,
very funny podcast.
Um,
uh,
thank you to the flashlight
for sponsoring the show.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click the
link and enter in the code name Rogan,
you get 15% off.
Um,
Louisville Improv.
I don't know if there's
tickets still available.
There wasn't,
wasn't very many left.
Um,
but it's this Wednesday night
with me and my man Tom Segura.
Shit's jumping off and
then we'll be back at,
um,
we'll be back at Sal's
comedy hold next Wednesday.
And uh,
we will also have a
couple podcast next week.
I've got a couple of good things cooking,
so,
uh,
Brian Cowen will be on this Friday.
So,
uh,
that's,
that'll be the next one.
And A,
and I'll also put up the podcast
on a plane with Ari Shaffir.
Alright.
That's it.
Pitches,
that's the end of this.
Fantastical it.
And listen to our Steve Oh,
podcasts over at the desk
squad and our blog out.
Yeah.
Don't listen to the blackout one UFC
blackout and the super black and yeah,
the UFC blackout.
Maybe that's super blackout one.
I'm gonna step in and intervene.
And Joe,
you got to listen to it
at least before you ate.
Gij It's hilarious.
Gets drunk with crazy broads and like
literally they get hammered and slobber
over each other and
threatened to kill each other.
Why would anyone want to watch that?
All right,
folks.
Yeah.
Well have you got nothing to do?
Check it out.
Alright,
bitches.
We will,
uh,
we'll see you soon on Friday and I'll
see you crazy freaks and Louisville,
Kentucky.
And maybe I could talk
you out of escaping,
creating something
better in Louisville by,
that'd be a bit of an okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Come on on machine.